ach zusammen herzlich willkommen an
euren empfangsgeräten zu zdf heute
leifermann ihren live stream zu
aktuellen diskussion und ereignissen und
1 beziehungsweise 2 haben wir
tatsächlich heute vor uns denn wir
starten mit den heutigen tag ins
superwahljahr
da sind ganze oder ist gerade ton
angegangen history da sind ganze fünf
landtagswahlen drei kommunalwahlen eine
wahl zum abgeordnetenhaus und dann noch
so eine bundestagswahl vor uns im
september das heißt wir können kräftig
viele kreuzchen machen und die baden
württemberger und rheinland pfälzer
haben damit angefangen heute haben
kräftigere kreuze gemacht für ihre
landtagswahlen bis jetzt sieht es so aus
zumindest was die prognosen hergeben das
alles so bleiben könnte wie es ist aber
trotzdem ist es ein spannender wahlabend
weil man weiß es ja alles nicht so genau
wir wollen die nächsten drei stunden mit
euch zusammen hier
diese waren ergebnisse zusammen
beobachten in einer stunde schließen die
wahllokale
das heißt falls ihr gerade noch in
baden-württemberg oder rheinland-pfalz
seit und noch kein kreuzchen gemacht
habt habt ihr noch
ja ich sage mal 57 minuten um dahin zu
dann vielleicht habt ihr aber auch schon
briefwahl gemacht weil das war auch ganz
groß im trend dieses jahr
wir möchten mit expertinnen über die
wahl reden wir schalten gleich ins zdf
wahlstudio wird zu schalten ins zdf
hauptstadtstudio und versuchen außerdem
all eure fragen zu beantworten eure
kommentare wie immer wenn sie sich im
rahmen des zivilen dialoges bewegen sehr
gerne und herzlich willkommen entweder
an diese adresse hier unten
falls sie in der app zuschaut oder in
die dafür vorgesehenen kommentarspalten
hier links oben rechts kunden wo auch
immer die uns gerade kurze und wir
fangen jetzt gleich mal an und schalten
zu meinem kollegen simon franz nach
studio in unser zdf wahlstudio simon
bist du da ich bin da ja es wurde
richtig knapp gerade weil bis gerade
eben die allerletzte probe lief und wir
wirklich gucken musste dass wir noch
rechtzeitig hier im studio kommt erstmal
daniel freue ich mich dass wir diesen
wahl haben heute gemeinsam begleiten
werden vielleicht hält er einige
überraschungen bereit mal gucken hier
ist jetzt im moment ein bisschen die
ruhe vor dem sturm wie gesagt bis gerade
eben hat probe da wurde gedruckt
sind ihre partner in ihren position zb
stehen alle leitungen und ist dann auch
alles wirklich bereit für die sendung
und das braucht natürlich sehr viel
technik und die kennt ihr jetzt auch
hier im hintergrund sehen wir können es
jetzt bei dir sehen du trägst natürlich
die obligatorische maske weil es ist
eine wahlsendung in corona zeiten und da
ist alles ein bisschen anders als sonst
oder absolut alles anders es ist für
einfach alles größer wenn ich hier mal
guckt das in der die position an den um
19 uhr dann die spitzenkandidaten sein
werden früher saßen wir alle oder
standen an so einem kleinen runden tisch
mittlerweile sehr viel mehr platz um
eben die notwendigen abstände
einzuhalten
als wir heute hier ankam da gab es einen
chor oder test er war freiwillig aber
für jeden möglich da eigentlich ankam
wurde gerade gesagt es seien 700 test
gemacht worden und von denen ein negativ
also toi toi toi dass das heute auch
unterkante bedingungen guter abend fehlt
was gibt denn heute nicht was
normalerweise gegangen wäre also dass
schon gesagt gruppenkuscheln in der
elefantenrunde ist heute nicht drin aber
gibt es noch mehr beschränkungen
es setzt sich auch für die reporterinnen
und reporter ganz schwierig ja früher
wenn da ein spitzenkandidat jetzt aus
der staatskanzlei kamen oder so dass er
natürlich viele teams auf den zugestimmt
und den besten den schnellsten o ton zu
bekommen und das geht natürlich jetzt
nicht also man muss gucken dass man
diese pult bildung vermeidet und man
muss auch immer sagen
der gesundheitsschutz steht hier vor dem
besten bild so die hier noch umschauen
bei mir die ersten kommentare und fragen
ein zu diesem superwahljahr mit dem wir
heute starten sieht man wir schalten
nach ja nochmal zu dir über dann wirst
du die position gewechselt haben und vom
landtag in baden württemberg in
stuttgart stehen
das hierhin vielen dank danke für die
einblicke und dieses superwahljahr mit
denen wir quasi heute den startschuss
gegeben haben das gucken wir uns mal an
zusammen mit jan frederik fischer in
rheinland pfalz und baden württemberg
ist der startschuss gefallen für das
superwahljahr 20 21
in mainz lag die spd mit
ministerpräsidentin dreier laut
politbarometer zuletzt vor der cdu die
mit dem eher unbekannten
spitzenkandidaten walldorf antritt in
stuttgart hingegen führte der grüne
ministerpräsident kretschmann vor der
cdu der droht mit ihrer
spitzenkandidatin eisenmann auch im
ländle eine niederlage doch wer gewinnt
wer verliert tatsächlich die korona
krise macht die wahlen so spannend wie
nie wahlveranstaltung wandern ins netz
wähler müssen mit abstand überzeugt
werden und das virus selbst wird zum
thema nummer eins nächste station
sachsen anhalt hier gibt es im juni
einen weiteren fingerzeig für das große
finale
das findet am 26 september statt wenn
die bürger nicht nur drei weiteren
bundesländern ihre kreuze machen sollen
sondern in ganz deutschland ausgang
offen und überraschung nicht
ausgeschlossen nur eins ist klar
angela merkel will nach 16 jahren als
kanzlerin schluss machen
jetzt habe ich ihn simon zu früh
verabschiedet du bist ja immer noch da
du willst erst leicht wechseln weil ich
wollte mit dir nochmal über die themen
reden wir haben das schon gesehen oder
gehört so ein paar themen die heute
wichtig fahren was ist denn aus seiner
perspektive seiner wahrnehmung die die
themen gewesen die in baden-württemberg
und in rheinland-pfalz jetzt richtig
gezogen haben
also wir haben ja in diesem wahlkampf
immer wieder auch straßenumfragen
gemacht und die menschen gefragt was
interessiert sie
und das war eigentlich immer das thema
corona und all diese themen die mit
corona zusammenhängen also jetzt in der
letzten wahlkampfwoche ging es nochmal
starkes thema bildung aber natürlich in
dem sinne waren öffnen die schulen wie
lange müssen sie dicht bleiben wo das
ging sehr viel das thema wirtschaft aber
da natürlich immer unter diesem
gesichtspunkt wie kommt man aus dieser
corona pandemie so gut wie möglich
wieder raus das war jetzt gibt es hier
schon die ersten fragen noch mal ab wann
gibt es die ersten hochrechnungen
beziehungsweise gibt es schon
hochrechnungen
ja es gibt zumindest umfragen von
zdf-politbarometer die ersten zahlen
haben wir euch auch in die kommentare
gepackt die links da könnt ihr schon mal
gucken was dabei herausgekommen ist bei
uns jetzt richtig um 18 uhr heiße mode
können auch um 18 uhr gibt keine
hochrechnung sondern die erste prognose
und dann wird man sehen müssen wie
schnell dass die erste hochrechnung gibt
weil durch diesen hohen briefwahl anteil
dieses mal ist es ein bisschen schwierig
dann auch eine hochrechnung zu machen
weil man eben nur diese exit polstern
hat also sozusagen am wahllokal menschen
befragen kann aber man hat nicht so
richtigen gefühl dafür was da bei der
briefwahl rauskam also das wird noch
spannend heute abend genau diese
briefwahl die hat einiges ändern über
dieser wahl zumindest ist das eine
vermutung was da genau dahinter steht
das hat uns herr kugel zusammengefasst
zwischen home office und feierabend zu
hause die geheimen kreuze setzen
unterschrift auf dem separaten
wahlschein nicht vergessen und ab damit
mehr als die hälfte der stimmen wird
diesmal wohl per brief eingehen rekord
beim letzten mal wählte in baden
württemberg etwa jeder fünfte sog in
rheinland pfalz fast jeder dritte die
wahlgrundsätze frei und geheim gelten
natürlich auch in den eigenen vier
wänden
wenn zum beispiel das enkelkind die oma
nötigt in seinem sind zu wählen muss die
standhaft bleiben
das bundesverfassungsgericht sagt
standard ist die urnenwahl aber wählen
im wohnzimmer wird akzeptiert das ist
wohl nie so wichtig wie jetzt um
kontakte zu vermeiden oder langes warten
würden sonst womöglich viele ihre stimme
verfallen lassen
die briefwahl wird ermöglicht zurecht
auch weil es nicht hohe wahlbeteiligung
geben soll und man es allen dann auch
ermöglichen möchte da sie an der wahl
teilnehmen können auch die briefwahl
stimmen werden erst am wahlsonntag
ausgezählt dabei darf jeder zuschauer
der sich davon überzeugen will
ob alles korrekt abläuft nur wenn die
namen im wählerverzeichnis stehen sind
die anonymen stimmzettel aus den blauen
umschlägen gültig die werden ab 18 uhr
geöffnet
die stapel dann wahrscheinlich so hoch
wie noch nie
und im zdf wahlstudio in stuttgart ist
jetzt bei meinem kollegen simon schwanz
sind meine kollegin bettina schausten
die die sendung gleich operieren wird
simon kannst du mal weil die kinder hat
gerade kann keine nur stück und ein
ohrwurm wie wir das nennen drin sie mal
fragen haben wir jetzt eigentlich
eingepreist nachher bei den ersten
prognosen das ist diese brief vor allem
gibt also sind die überhaupt verlässt
nicht ich blieb die frage gerne weiter
bettina schausten noch mitten in der
vorbereitung für die heutige sendung
unsere zuschauer interessiert wie
zuverlässig denn diese 18 uhr prognose
sein kann durch diesen umstand dass sehr
viele menschen briefwahl gemacht haben
ja das macht es natürlich schwerer
tatsächlich für für die demoskopen die
haben uns das schon auch erklärt von der
forschungsgruppe wahlen die sind ja
sonst oft wirklich sehr sehr passgenau
durch die sogenannten exit-polls das
wirklich eben gefragt wird die
wählerinnen und wähler die aus der
kabine kommen das werden jetzt weniger
sein es gibt eben mehr leute die schon
per briefwahl
gewählt haben und jetzt müssen die
demoskopen erfahrungswerte einberechnen
auch darin sind sie gut aber sie weisen
schon darauf hin dass das so ein zwei
punkte mehr spiel drin ist in der
prognose also die tendenz wird gut sein
und daraus kann man dann auch schon ganz
viel ablesen aber so ganz haargenau
scharf das ergebnis schon zu treffen das
wird schwieriger jetzt sein wenn man ja
die umfragen relativ eindeutig in beiden
bundesländern die regierungschefs weit
vorne
wird das tier war in ihren augen ein
langweiliger warten wenn man erstmal ist
natürlich nie weil abend langweilig und
ich glaube dass es jetzt richtig viel
musik gibt die mir drin ist in diesem
wahlabend selbst wenn man durch die form
fragen schon ahnt wer vorne an der
spitze liegt aber gerade in der
bündnisfrage ich glaube da liegt ganz
viel drin und dann auch natürlich die
große frage wie schneidet die cdu hat
die jetzt die masken affäre ja noch
hatte die natürlich auch ein stück weit
verantwortlich gemacht wird für die
ganze krisenstrategie in sachen corona
die einen neuen bundesvorsitzenden hat
die hat noch nicht ihre
kanzlerkandidatur geklärt die union also
das sind alles jetzt so punkte die
schwingen hier schon mit
es geht hier nicht nur um weiland preis
und baden württemberg heute abend
sondern es geht eben tatsächlich auch
schon jetzt um den aufgalopp zur
bundestagswahl und das macht einfach
heute abend in mailand auf spannend und
abschließen sie haben wir unzählige
wahlsendung schon moderiert
bundestagswahl us us-wahl europawahlen
landtagswahlen ganz ganz viele jetzt die
erste unter pandemie bedingungen wie
ändert sich die arbeiten also ist schon
ein bisschen speziell muss ich sagen ich
mach das tatsächlich seit 2003 diese
wahlsendung
ihr habt das ja glaube ich auch gezeigt
hier das setting ist viel vergrößert wir
haben diese runde anders anordnen müssen
wir müssen auf abstand bleiben
es sind alle getestet worden ihr müsst
mit maske arbeiten unsere reporterin
reporter
da sieht man heute nur die augen und die
müssen deutlich sprechen
also das sind schon erschwerte
bedingungen aber trotzdem ich bin froh
dass wir es doch vor ort machen können
weil man bekommt einfach schon mehr mit
und wir werden hier eben von stuttgart
aus ja genauso auch rheinland pfalz in
den blick nehmen also müssen wir jetzt
mit leben geht ja nicht anders und beim
nächsten mal bei der bundestagswahl ist
es von mir schon besser und war vielen
dank der tina und wir geben jetzt zurück
zu daniel danke dir simon wir sprechen
auf jeden fall nachher nochmal weiter
auch mit titelchancen im laufe des
abends immer noch denn wir wollen hier
online bleiben bis ungefähr 20 uhr
bisher zumindest eine grobe ahnung davon
haben wie der wahlabend ausgegangen ist
in der ungefähr 45 minuten schließen die
wahllokale
und natürlich waren unsere reporter
innen schon den ganzen
wegs in baden-württemberg und in
rheinland-pfalz um zu gucken wie die
stimmung an den wahllokalen ist und
meine kolleginnen zusammen von lojewski
und julia schröter habe das mal für uns
zusammengefasst
der gang an die wahlurne unter pandemie
bedingungen
seit dem morgen sind in rheinland-pfalz
3,1 millionen bürgerinnen und bürger zur
stimmabgabe aufgerufen
die situation im wahllokal mit corona
etwas besonderes im gegensatz zu den
vorjahren müssen halt jedes mal nach
jedem wahlvorgang die wahlkabine
desinfiziert werden
es dürfen immer nur eine sehr begrenzte
zahl von wählern auch im wahlraum selbst
sein der umgang mit der pandemie war im
wahlkampf das beherrschende thema aber
nicht das einzige müssen um die
wirtschaft dass wir da wirtschaftsfragen
geklebt bekommen dass man in der bildung
in rheinland pfalz sind weiter kommen ja
förderung der jugendlichen jungen leute
ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer wählte
am morgen an ihrem wohnort in trier
sie hat gute chancen mit ihrer spd
erneut stärkste kraft zu werden
knapp dahinter in umfragen liegt
christian baldauf von der cdu er machte
schon am montag briefwahl die masken
affäre der union sei kein rückenwind im
wahlkampf gewesen zur waldorf
profitieren könnte die cdu von der
rekordzahl an briefwählern
viele könnten ihr kreuzchen schon
gemacht haben bevor die affäre große
wellen schlug gewissheit bringt erst der
wahlabend und der dürfte spannend werden
in rheinland pfalz er ist in baden
württemberg der favorit winfried
kretschmann heute morgen bei der
stimmabgabe mit seiner ehefrau jeder
wahltag sei ein guter tag für die
demokratie so der amtierende
ministerpräsident pandemie bedingt
stimmte cdu-spitzenkandidatin susanne
eisenmann nur per briefwahl ab so wie
viele stimmberechtigte die wenigsten
wähler erwarten einen wechsel im ländle
auf jeden fall im bereich klima dann
muss mir passieren auch wenn ihr die
autobauer stadt ist die hohe zahl an
briefwählern ist für die
meinungsforscher heute eine besondere
herausforderung aufgrund der
unwägbarkeiten heute auch
der vielleicht geringeren beteiligung
der wählerinnen und wähler in den
wahllokalen müssen wir einfach ein
bisschen größere unsicherheit
einkalkulieren und sollten uns
vielleicht nicht so genau auf die 18 uhr
prognose verlassen hier im zdf
wahlstudio stuttgart steht alles bereit
wenn es heute um 17.30 losgeht genau 17
30 geht's los wird dabei ist mein
kollege carsten behrendt der natürlich
auch eine maske trägt hallo kasten
schade der ton funktioniert doch nicht
wie es aussieht also zumindest höre ich
dich nicht ich kann mir ihr versucht es
mal kurz zu fixen kasten ich kann euch
zumindest mal sagen weil es gab hier
tragen in der zuschauerschaft was mit
den massen ist warum zum beispiel jetzt
gerade meine kollegin bettina schausten
keiner auf hat und wie das mit den tests
war also die kolleginnen war natürlich
schon geschminkt das ist bei mir auch
immer der fall wenn du geschminkt ist
und dann der maske aufsetzt kannst du
die schminke gleich wieder von der maske
kratzen das macht ein wenig sind
deswegen tragen alle anderen immer
massen und dann gab es eine frage mit
den schnelltest die waren freiwillig
aber soweit ich weiß haben alle
mitarbeiter innen vor ort im wahlstudio
und heißt gemacht einfach weil er
freiwillig war aber trotzdem miteinander
mitgemacht und die war negativ ich hoffe
dass haben erst geklärt so carsten hast
du was an deinem handy ändern können
dass wir das mit dem ton in kriegen
probiert auch noch mal sieht nicht so
aus leider können wir beide keine
gebärdensprache dhm checken das also du
kannst mit höheren kosten das ist genuss
einer echten zoom konferenz hier nass
oder skype oder was auch immer du musst
den ton an machen carsten ja wir wissen
dass noch mal wir aber in der
zwischenzeit gehen wir mal zurück zu
dankeschön kassen für die kleine
tanzeinlage so simon ist aber noch im
wahlstudio und kann mich auch noch hören
oder
wir sind noch in bei studien müssen aber
gleich raus denn gleich geht hier die
live sendung los alles klar erst mal
aber ich habe mir noch zwei drei fragen
vielleicht kannst du die beantworten
ab wann darf mit hochrechnungen rechnen
oder prognosen da gab es so eine uhr
zeit haben wir da schon beantwortet 18
uhr kannst du kannst du vielleicht noch
mal kurz erklären unterschied prognose
und hochrechnungen ja also bei einer
prognose da geht es eben eine
wesentliche um diese exit polls also das
was sagen die leute im wahllokal gerade
gewählt haben unseren demoskopen und bei
der hochrechnung der fließen dann über
den abend immer weiter tatsächlich
ausgezählten stimmen mit ein
und so kommt man dann irgendwann zu
diesem allgemeinen endergebnis wo es
dann eben nur noch um die stimmen gehe
sondern gibt es eine frage ob es auch
entgeht dass man parteien raus wählt das
ist ja relativ einfach möglich indem die
weniger stimmen kriegen als fünf prozent
das wollte carey wissen
hier gibt es übrigens eine schöne
diskussion über das thema cannabis das
ist relativ youtube spezifisch simon das
ist die aber auch schon untergekommen in
den letzten wochen
ich kann dich leider ganz schlecht hören
ich hätte ich nur ganz leise ich habe
die frage leider nicht schade nicht gäbe
das stichwort cannabis das wird hier
munter diskutiert das thema hattest du
ja auch schon aber ist im wahlkampf
nicht so richtig groß gewesen
nee das ist in der tat so also wir
erleben das natürlich dass sehr viele
junge menschen unter anderem auch in den
kommentaren bei uns bei youtube dass er
sein ganz relevantes thema sehen
ich sage es mal bei den großen parteien
hat das im wahlkampf keine große rolle
gespielt in ihren bei programmen sind
natürlich die allermeisten auch
positioniert aber im wahlkampf bei den
veranstaltungen da war das doch eher
noch ein thema so simon
du musst raus weil vielleicht geht die
sender muss in zehn minuten sitzen und
30 die bremer aber hier online und die
wichtigsten sachen die bei uns im zdf im
fernsehen laufen
die werden wir hier auch durch schalten
das heißt ihr könnt auch sehr gerne hier
bei uns bleiben die wichtigsten sachen
wenn er den mitbekommen und hier werden
wir miteinander weiter diskutieren
simon vielen dank bis hierhin wir sehen
uns oder höhere uns gleich nochmal
weiter und jetzt höre ich dass carsten
mithören kann ich hoffe du hast den
richtigen schalter gefunden kassen
ich sag nur reboot tut immer gut einmal
die app neu gestartet und ich hoffe
jetzt können wir uns super haben sie
schon versucht das gerät außen wieder
einzuschalten habe ich heute auch schon
von der wii zu hören bekommen so kahrs
und so ist ich sehe dich vor vielen
bildschirmen sitzen was machst du denn
heute eigentlich ja ich meine das ist
auch experimental charakter sowie unser
gespräch jetzt hier gerade wir gucken
darauf was die parteien online an
wahlpartys machen denn so wie der
wahlkampf halt war so sind eben auch die
partys passend zu dem abend alles
digital sehr experimentell
wie wir hören von den parteien da gibt's
vom digitalen kaffeekränzchen bis zum
großen auftritt der kandidaten und
künstlern auch also einige haben auch
gesagt dass die künstlerinnen
unterstützen wollen in der krise die
lassen sie dann bei ihren wahlpartys
auftreten also wir erwarten hier ein
relativ bunten abend und gucken dass wir
zumindest bei den großen parteien einmal
reinschauen was die uns bieten und das
schöne ist halt auch dass wir es
schaffen auch geografisch hier ziemlich
große sprünge zu machen sowohl den baden
württemberg
einfach in rheinland-pfalz also wir sind
zum beispiel zu gast in mannheim der
zweitgrößten stadt hier von baden
württemberg und auch in karlsruhe in der
drittgrössten da sind da zum beispiel
bei den linken und gucken da mal zu
wir sind auf das schwäbischen alb bei
der cdu da haben wir uns auch brav
angemeldet weil man muss dabei legen wir
gucken bei den menschen ins wohnzimmer
rein und da sind wir natürlich keine
unangemeldeten gäste die da einfach
stalken und in rheinland-pfalz zb bei
der spd da gibt es eine digitale
wahlparty da schauen wir dann auch zu
also ich muss mal kurz in den kommentare
gucken einigermaßen friedlich läuft es
auf youtube ab auf facebook aber geht es
so da möchte ich doch mal zur saison
rufen und auch ein bisschen zur
sachlichkeit denn mit solchen
kommentaren wie ich dir gerade diese
kommen wir hier nicht wirklich weiter
heute abend haben sich denn die parteien
für ihre digitalen welt hat irgendwas
besonderes überlegt also gibt's da
irgendwie jetzt auftritte oder dj sets
oder choreografin mit 500 leuten in so
einem gruppenraum
wir haben eben bei der fdp die haben
einen stream aus der bundeszentrale in
berlin schon gesehen ein gitarrenduo das
war glaube ich vorab aufgezeichnet das
war so ein bisschen der wurm abteil
aber ich habe davor vor unserem gespräch
hier gesprochen mit jürgen von oertzen
der ist bei den grünen in karlsruhe
aktiv und hat da diese digitale
wahlparty organisiert und wenn die
technik mitspielt dann können vielleicht
unsere kollegen in der regie das mal
abfahren was er uns erzählt hat
wir versuchen so gut es geht trotzdem
kontakt herzustellen
das ist das gemeinschaftsgefühl zu
schaffen nach sechs wochen wahlkampf
oder für vier bis sechs monate wahlkampf
und da ein bisschen verbindung zu
schaffen wir haben so schöne kärtchen
vorbereitet hier jemand in die kamera
halten kann ich gut erholt und wenn es
gut läuft dann haben wir auch was zu
trinken da und dann gucken wir mal wie's
klar wir haben ein tippspiel
jeder jede durfte sagen was sie glaubt
wie wir abschneiden wie die andern
abschneiden machen ein kleines quiz und
ihre prognose gibt es grund zum feiern
heute haben für die grünen in baden
württemberg also wenn wir nicht die
stadtteilwehren das wird mich schon sehr
enttäuscht und dann wird es spannend ich
sah man geht ja gespannt sind wir auch
carsten bei dir sieht man schon so ein
bisschen weise wird glaube ich raten der
bei dem tippspiel immer vorne dabei dir
sieht man schon wissen was auf dem
bildschirm kann es noch mal kurz zeigen
das sieht sehr sehr bunt aus wer ist
denn das da gerade der so knallbunt auf
dem bildschirm liegt also hier haben wir
zum beispiel für tina schausten da läuft
noch die probe im wahlstudio
das ist hier unten links ist meinte er
in form gleich von unserer wahl sendung
ja daniel ich muss noch mal ein bisschen
hier dramaturgie aufbauen ja nicht so
wir haben noch keine zeichen wäre
herzlich ist auch der martin ja ich mir
trotzdem muss ich den kollegen
vorstellen der martin hier der ist
nämlich mein meister und klammert das
alles ab und bomber und bund ja das ist
die fdp die da so bonbon bund daher
kommt und da war auch schon christian
lindner vorab zu hören
martin kann ja vielleicht mal kurz
zeigen so läuft es dann ab was christian
lindner gesagt hat wir wie es ihm geht
mit diesem mit dieser wahl party aber
ich sehe das richtig die fdp wie sehr
vermissen den kontakt mit den menschen
okay man hat es mal ganz wenig kosten
aber ich sehe das richtig dass die fdp
im oberen drittel jemanden darunter
leide aber dass tatsächlich einfach nur
ne fahne aufgehängt hat hat mal ganz
kurz
welchen oben rechts welchen meiner
10.000 monitore meinst du gerade rechts
den tja da oben rechtlich sollte dieses
ist ja genau da oben rechts das das ist
tatsächlich der livestream gerade von
der fdp aus berlin da ist glaube ich
jemand gerade zugeschaltet und redet da
ich gerade dich auf dem kopfhörer habe
kann ich da nicht zu hören
aber ja so sieht es gerade aus bei dem
offiziellen stream der bundes-fdp schön
bunt ok mut zur authentizität würde ich
das ganze man nennt carsten du wohl aber
das ist ganz so weiter für uns die
ganzen livestreams ich wünsche dir einen
schönen platz abend mit den ganzen
verschiedenen wahlpartys bis später so
und ich habe versucht bekommt den von
ihr bei mir im studio ist christian
sievers hey christian hallo daniel tun
oder wie es nachher die 19 uhr ausgabe
jahren der heute das wird ja auch ein
bisschen andere ausgabe als sonst was
habt ihr da so vor
das ist unsere klassische wahl
sonntagsausgabe wenn man so will das
schöne an der 19 uhr heute sendung ist
ja 20 minuten und man erfährt kompakt
alles wichtige ich sag immer geben sie
uns 20 minuten sie bekommen von uns die
welt und heute ist das natürlich sehr
viel wahlen
wir haben die aktuellsten hochrechnung
wir hoffen dass wir die erste
hochrechnung dann schon haben kommt
heute ein bisschen später wegen viel
viel briefwahl in rheinland-pfalz und in
baden-württemberg
und wir haben sämtliche
spitzenkandidatin und spitzenkandidaten
das ist natürlich auch so eine tradition
kann man schon sagen immer punkt 19 uhr
versammeln die sich in unseren wald
studios in stuttgart und in mainz und
sind dann natürlich auch in der sendung
und wir gucken auf die bundespolitik die
weiterungen die das ganze hat dann auch
eventuell auch für berlin ist ja auch
ein wichtiges thema heute
und natürlich was wir auch nicht
vergessen dürfen es gibt nur andere
nachrichten in dieser welt außer den
landtagswahlen und auch das ist
natürlich teil der sind also ein
all-inclusive-paket heute abend ja wie
immer
das ist das schöne an der sendung aber
noch ein bisschen größer als sonst
jetzt gucken wir auf die briefwahl wird
schon diskutiert irgendwie wie viele das
sein könnten ob das irgendwie welche
unmengen man erwartet und viele nick
mediadesign schreibt ich will nicht
wissen wie viele frühere brief federn
und nicht mehr cdu csu gewählt haben
also das ist auch eine große spannende
frage heute glaubst du denn dass wir um
19 uhr wenn ihr drauf geht tatsächlich
schon einigermaßen verlässliche zahlen
haben
also einigermaßen verlässliche auf jeden
fall meinen erfahrungen mit der
forschungsgruppe wahlen die sind
großartig also da sind ja die zahlen
normalerweise sage ich jetzt mal unter
normalen bedingungen dermaßen exakt dass
man wirklich sagen muss ihr seid
fantastisch auch schon um 18 uhr häufig
das wird heute ein bisschen anders sein
einfach weil natürlich briefwähler die
vor den wahllokalen nicht befragt werden
können
eben aus der statistik herausfallen und
dann ist es ein bisschen schwieriger da
muss man mit ein paar unbekannten
arbeiten aber ich bin da sehr
zuversichtlich dass die kolleginnen und
kollegen das so gemanagt kriegen dass
wir um 19 oder schon klaren trend haben
genau mit dem haben wir heute gesprochen
mit matthias jung vom
meinungsforschungsinstitut
forschungsgruppe wahlen zu diesem
problem und der brief mit den zahlen und
das gucken uns erst mal an
wir haben zum ersten mal eine
landtagswahl oder zwei landtagswahlen
mit einer sehr hohen
briefwahlbeteiligung in rheinland-pfalz
fml der briefwahlstimmen als unwahr
stimmen und die befragung die wir vor
den wahllokalen für die 18 uhr prognosen
machen die kommen eben normalerweise von
den wählern und deshalb fehlen uns viele
briefwähler
wir haben natürlich aus der
vergangenheit erfahrungswerte die wir
jetzt durch simulationen versuchen hier
auf die situation zu übertragen um dann
die in den vor den wahllokalen
gemessenen ergebnisse damit zu
korrigieren wir haben uns in den letzten
jahren daran gewöhnt dass wir nur
zehntel abweichungen zwischen der 18 uhr
prognose in dem endergebnis haben
aufgrund der unwägbarkeiten heute auch
der vielleicht geringeren beteiligung
der wählerinnen und wähler in den
wahllokalen müssen wir einfach ein
bisschen größere unsicherheit
einkalkulieren und sollten uns
vielleicht nicht so genau auf die 18 uhr
prognose verlassen wie das sonst der
fall gewesen
ja das wird also ganz spannend christian
du hast ja auch schon ganz viele
wahlsendungen als der zahlen moderator
gemacht wo man dann die ganzen balken
vorliest was hast du denn da schon
erlebt und jetzt so unwägbarkeiten und
und merkwürdigkeiten die dann vielleicht
zahlen die sich änderten oder so zahlen
die sich drehten
also mein vater sagte immer als ich das
wurde sagt er wieso haben sie denn
ausgerechnet ich genommen hätten sie
nicht jemanden finden können der
mathematik kann
er hat dann auch so erinnerungen an
meine schuld sache halt im kopf gehabt
es gibt wahnsinnig viele leute im
hintergrund die das machen tolle
computersysteme und vor allem die
kolleginnen kollegen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen
und es kann alles passieren das ist ja
ein euro job also dieser 18 uhr
geschichte speziell wenn die wahllokale
schließen die erste prognose kommt und
die in vielen fällen schon sehr sehr
genau ist und du dann was hast was du
beim fernsehen ganz selten hast du
guckst du in eine kamera ein und spürst
geradezu wie am anderen ende in diversen
wahlpartys entweder jubel ausbricht moda
die leute anfangen zu weinen sogar also
die emotionen wirklich hoch kochen du du
hast das gefühl dass du quasi mit dem
was du da als bote über bringst auf der
einen seite karrieren machst auf der
anderen seite karriere zerstören kannst
in der politik das ist natürlich du bist
nicht die die die nachricht sondern nur
der bote bei der ganzen geschichte aber
das ist immer ein ganz besonderer moment
unter kribbelt glaube ich bei jedem der
damit befasst ist in diesem wald studios
im fernsehen an so einem wahlabend
das ist eine unglaubliche
herausforderung auch und vor allem heißt
es immer wieder
wir dürfen nichts falsch machen weil da
ein fehler ein zahlendreher oder
irgendwie eine ungenauigkeit ist
natürlich verheerend und deswegen achten
der doppelt und dreifach darauf dass wir
das alles sehr sehr korrekt hinkriegen
aber gab es schon mal eine handvoll fans
näher was ist immer gibt ist natürlich
dass du mal ein technisches problem hast
du texter drauf und dann kommt dieser
einsamen berg nicht hoch ja und du musst
noch mal wieder drauf tatschen das haben
wir auch bei der us wahl erlebt da
passiert das zwischendurch immer mal
wieder was so richtige zahlen probleme
angeht hatten wir zum glück noch nicht
aber natürlich hast du immer mal so
einen dreher darin dass du dich ein
bisschen versprichst oder so das musste
dann ganz schnell korrigieren aber
speziell zu diesen besonderen momenten
also 18 uhr dann die erste hochrechnung
darf wirklich nichts schief laufen also
da ist die konzentration auch so groß
dass da absolut nichts schief gehen da
gab es denn eine wahl natürlich erinnert
wo tatsächlich das nicht noch gedreht
hat also wo es erst so außer partei iks
kommt rein und kann doch nicht rein oder
btx führt und dann kippte das doch
wieder das passe ja relativ häufig
gerade diese fünf prozent hürde dieses
zittern um die um den einzug einer
bestimmten partei und dann die frage und
das ändert dann ja oft alles also die
gesamte gemenge lage wenn die partei
drin ist gibt es wieder eine komplett
neue sitzverteilung und damit auch neue
koalitionsoptionen wenn die partei nicht
drin
fallen wieder koalitionsoptionen raus
das heißt das kann diesen wahlabend dann
ganz schön in die länge zieht und macht
die natürlich am ende dann aber auch so
spannend also ein wahlabend der um 18
uhr gelaufen ist ist natürlich so von
der spannung her überschaubar und an
wahlabend bei dem man sagt okay wir sind
wirklich noch stunden daran und und sind
immer noch am ausloten wie es nun genau
aussieht dass er hält die spannung hatte
man vorher nicht auf die zahlen heute
gucke ich sag mal auf unsere
projektionen der wahl von der
forschungsgruppe wahlen vielleicht mal
kurz auf meinem rechner schalten ich
habe das mal drauf gelegt politbarometer
extra von uns da haben wir 34 prozent
für die grünen 24 für den cdu fdp spd
fdp 3 für die linke und sieben andere
das land baden württemberg das sieht
jetzt nicht so aus als ob das heute
tatsächlich ganz eng werden könnte oder
christian das sieht es nicht so aus es
ganz eng werden könnte was das spannende
heute an der wahl ist es neben der frage
natürlich wie 7 die neuen regierungen
aus da wird sich möglicherweise ja bei
koalitionen noch das eine oder andere
auch wenn es von den amtsinhaberinnen
amtsinhaber vielleicht nicht ganz so
überraschend werden wird zumindest was
wir im moment da sehen dann ist die
andere große frage natürlich gibt es
ganz neue optionen von koalitionen also
gibt es mögliche ampel geschichten die
da im raum bestehen da sie und dann ist
die große frage was heißt das alles für
die bundespolitik das natürlich etwas
was über die landesgrenzen von baden
württemberg und rheinland pfalz hinaus
doch für interesse ist an diesem
wahlabend als glaube es wird auf jeden
fall ein spannender weil alles
besprechen wir nachher auch mit der
kollegin andrea maurer die ist für uns
in berlin parat und wird uns alle fragen
beantworten also wenn ihr fragen habt
zum verlauf der wahl zu den möglichen
koalitionen die es gibt zu der aus frage
wie quasi dieses wahlergebnis die
bundespolitik beeinflussen wird alles in
die kommentarspalten hier links rechts
neben auch immer ihr wollt oder per mail
an zdf heute - live at zdf.de
dann wird das hier bei mir eingereicht
so eine große sache die wir ja hatten
eine eine große ist eine große affäre
über die wir auch in den nachrichten
viel berichtet haben ist die massen
affäre der union was das tatsächlich für
auswirkungen auf das wahlergebnis der
parteien heute haben kann das wissen wir
noch nicht das kann man nur
erahnen oder vielleicht auch nicht jeden
der briefwahl aber für alle die noch
nicht ganz mitbekommen haben oder nicht
mehr auf dem neuesten stand sind florian
neumann hat das ganze mal
zusammengefasst stand freitagabend das
ist schäbig und das ist endlich was im
ton gewohnt präsidial daherkommt ist
eigentlich nichts anderes als ein
wutausbruch minutenlang schimpft der
bundespräsidentin auf einer tagung der
faz über die masken deals einzelner und
den schaden den sie anrichten
deshalb verdienen die bekannt gewordenen
fälle persönlicher bereicherung nicht
nur empörung
sie sind gift für die demokratie wie
korrupt ist die unionsfraktion eine
frage die nicht nur heute gestellt wird
und auf die alle abgeordneten einzelnen
antworten sollen per ehrenerklärungen
dass sie sich anders als wohl ihre
ex-kollegen löbel und nüßlein nicht an
der vermittlung von masken bereichert
haben
zahlreiche dieser erklärungen liegen dem
zdf vor viele abgeordnete sind sauer auf
die ehemaligen kollegen und darauf dass
sie alle in einen topf geworfen werden
wie mathias middelberg ja sagt der
abgeordnete auch er habe einem
unternehmen aus seinem wahlkreis das für
die massenproduktion nach fördermitteln
fragte einen kontakt vermittelt das
würde er jederzeit wieder tun
ich finde man muss sich als abgeordneter
vor ort um die anliegen der bürger aber
auch eben von unternehmen kümmern
man darf das aber nicht vermischen mit
seinen persönlichen anliegen und sagen
aus so einer tätigkeit als anwalt für
den wahlkreis ziehe ich jetzt für mich
noch persönlich profit die
fraktionsspitze telefoniert und
vermeldet am abend erleichtert alle
unterschriften beisammen
wir freuen uns sehr über dieses
eindeutige ergebnis denn es ist für uns
ein ganz starkes fundament auf dem weg
aus der krise
die erklärungen sind eindeutig und jeder
weiß was es bedeutet wenn man hier nicht
die wahrheit erklären würde
solche kollegen hätten keinen platz mehr
in unsere fraktion doch fragwürdige
beziehungen wie etwa des nun ex
abgeordneten hauptmann zu aserbaidschan
wurden gar nicht abgefragt weshalb auch
mancher in der eigenen fraktion zweifelt
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn die abfrage
breiter gefasst worden wäre nicht nur
auf medizinisches gerät und masken
sondern dass alles auf den prüfstand
kommt auf den prüfstand sollen nun die
regeln für abgeordnete eine
transparenzoffensive nennt die union
dass sie will etwa bezahlte
interessenvertretungen durch abgeordnete
verbieten nebeneinkünfte ab 100000 euro
genau offenlegen wenn solche vorwürfe im
raum stehen dann ist natürlich eine
strategie damit umzugehen transparenz zu
schaffen es zu verriegeln
aber gerade diesen schwierigen bereich
exakt zu verriegeln ist wahnsinnig
schwierig insofern ist das jetzt
sicherlich auch ein stückweit
symbolpolitik ein stück symbolpolitik
ein stück echte bewegung unter druck
will die union nun regeln zustimmen die
sie bislang stets abgelehnt hatte eine
partei kämpft um ihren ruf und nebenbei
auch um die macht der hand darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit andrea maurer im
hauptstadtstudio in berlin hallo andrea
was heißt denn diese ganze geschichte
jetzt eigentlich für die union wir haben
gerade gehört so das image ist nicht so
richtig toll dabei aber kann das
tatsächlich jetzt größere auswirkungen
haben
ja das ist sozusagen nicht absehbar
völlig klar ist allerdings dass diese
affären für die union absolut zur unzeit
kommen also es ist super war ja du hast
eben auch schon gesagt die ihrer merkel
geht zu ende nicht nur in der union
sondern für uns alle und diese partei
geht natürlich wie alle parteien in
dieses superwahljahr und hat jetzt
sozusagen vor zwei wichtigen
landtagswahlen vor dem ersten zwei
wichtigen landtagswahlen in diesem jahr
eben in der woche davor drei
parteiaustritte vorzuweisen und diese
masken affäre und und musste ich eben
die frage gefallen lassen wie haltet ihr
es eigentlich mit dem geld dazu kommt ja
auch und das ist inhaltlich von der
masten affäre getrennt aber es ist eben
auch eine frage die da rein gehört diese
aserbaidschan connection in dem beitrag
geben es ist ja auch schon angeklungen
und das heißt so zu sagen es steht
dieses narrativ vom schwarzen filz im
raum ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich also es
ja auch diesen spiegel titel am freitag
womöglich gesehen also dass es ein
strukturelles problem der union sein
könnte dieser verdacht steht im raum und
die partei versucht natürlich jetzt
alles diesem narrativ diesem verdacht
entgegen zu treten es gibt eben diese
ehrenerklärung der abgeordneten die
läuft unter der rubrik die
fraktionsspitze greift hart durch
und es ist diese transparenz offensive
gestartet worden
heute hat dobrindt die spd aufgefordert
dieser transparenz offensive
diese diese transparenzregeln schnell im
bundestag gemeinsam mit der spd eben auf
den weg zu bringen
die spd das muss man auch sagen lässt
die union allerdings gerade im regen
stehen so kann man es vielleicht
ausdrücken also der parteichef der spd
hat ja heute ein interview gegeben in
der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung und da sagt er
das in teilen der union so ein bisschen
das prinzip herrscht eine hand wäscht
die andere und das waschmittel sei geld
und das ist natürlich harter tobak
wenn koalitionspartner so übereinander
sprechen allerdings ich habe eine frage
von joachim daheim auf facebook der
möchte wissen ehrenerklärung
da unterschriften zusammen in
anführungszeichen und was heißt das denn
jetzt ist der rest der fraktion um
schuldig andrea wie würdest du das
bewerten also die unschuldsvermutung
gilt natürlich und die abgeordneten
haben da ihre unterschrift und gegeben
und ihre ehre erklärt ich kann dazu
nichts anderes sagen also ich würde da
jetzt erstmal den den verdacht nicht
aufrechterhalten und tatsächlich ist es
so dass ja dass das da wo jetzt
tatsächlich auch aufgeräumt wird und
dass dieser verhaltenskodex der ja da
auch im raum steht eben nicht nur
lippenbekenntnis sein soll sondern dass
es da auch sanktionen geben soll
das ganze spielt natürlich aber auch
rein in eine partei die ebenso hat man
jedenfalls das gefühl nicht immer hat
durchgegriffen hat und das gefühl dass
das problem nicht immer hart an den
wurzeln gepackt hat also das beispiel
viele am tor der jahr 2018 nicht zur
landtagswahl nicht spitzenkandidat bei
den landtagswahlen in
mecklenburg-vorpommern wurde weil er
eben auch unter lobby verdacht stand und
aktienoptionen bekommen haben soll und
der jetzt aber spitzenkandidat für die
bundestagswahl in mecklenburg vorpommern
wurde und und nachfolger von angela
merkel und das spielt jetzt alles da
kommt jetzt alles irgendwie so hoch und
man hat einfach das gefühl dass die
union tatsächlich durchgreifen muss man
aufräumen muss ja es gibt ja auch also
jetzt viele kommentare hier die in die
richtung gehen was so nebeneinkünfte
angeht also wann man die abwasser sowie
anzeigen soll ich nimmer exemplare
stehen von harald schultz nebeneinkünfte
erst 100000 euro per anno offenlegen
sagt einmal sind die in der union noch
bei sinnen haben die noch irgend einer
erdung die meisten menschen müssen mit
weniger als 30.000 euro auskommen und
zwar hauptberuflich also hier wenig
verständnis dafür dass sich die union
gegen solche preistransparenz und nach
lobbyregister immer wieder gewährt hat
obwohl so richtig werden konnten sind ja
nicht es geht ja ein bisschen in die
richtung mehr transparenz im bundestag
oder
das steht tatsächlich jetzt auf dem plan
also das lobby register
das soll ja kommen darauf hat sich die
große koalition geeinigt
es geht jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen
um die frage ob jetzt sozusagen nur die
lobbyisten vermerkt werden die im
bundestag sozusagen einen ausgehen oder
ob auch festgehalten wird wer da mit wem
gesprochen hat und es so zu sagen so
einen fußabdruck in einem
gesetzgeberischen prozess geben soll wo
bürgerinnen und bürger eben auch
einsicht bekommen
in welchen lobby zusammenhängen
womöglich ein gesetz entstanden ist und
also dass lobbyregister das wird es
geben
gut wir schauen später nochmal zu dir
andrea wenn wir die ersten prognosen
haben und wissen wie sie ungefähr in
rheinland pfalz und baden württemberg
aussehen wird und gucken dann was das
ganze für die bundespolitik bedeutet
bisher aber erst mal vielen dank nach
berlin
so also wir haben noch bis zu den ersten
prognosen genau 17 minuten die nutzen
wir um mit professor doktor marc debus
zu sprechen politikwissenschaftler an
der uni mannheim der das ganze natürlich
auch die hauptberuflich analysiert
auseinandernimmt und jetzt mit uns
zusammen auseinander dröselt und erklärt
hallo herr professor debus also wie
blicken sie denn jetzt auf diese wahlen
noch dieses war ja natürlich auch mit
großer spannung gerade dahingehend
welche parteien miteinander versuchen
wollen zu koalieren einmal in rheinland
pfalz und natürlich auch in baden
württemberg was enorm spannend wird ist
natürlich die frage ob in baden
württemberg cdu und grüne weiter
regieren wollen oder können tun sie es
wahrscheinlich im hinblick auf ihre
stärke oder ob es hier eine ablösung
gibt im hinblick auf eine ampelkoalition
oder einfach es für grüne und spd eine
rot grüne koalition aber mittels
faszinierend dass im endeffekt auch dass
wir hier im endeffekt sogar spekulieren
über eine mögliche grüne gelbe
koalitionsmehrheit so was hätte man sich
vor ein paar jahren oder monaten
eigentlich nicht vorstellen können ja
allerdings in rheinland pfalz sind ja
die grünen mit der fdp schon zusammen in
der ampelkoalition allerdings unter
führung der spd
das hat ja relativ gut klappt zumindest
was man so aus dem land hört was haben
denn die parteien da richtig gemacht
parteien müssen sich nach den nach den
wahlen beziehungsweise in den
koalitionsverhandlungen dann auf
kompromisse einigen schließt eine reihe
von sachen einen beispielsweise
natürlich dann die sachfragen die im
endeffekt quasi ausgehandelt werden
müssen um dem koalitionsabkommen
einschließen und natürlich kommt es auch
darauf an wie die personen jeweils
miteinander auskommen und ob man es auch
gewohnt ist miteinander in koalitionen
regieren zu können
und es schien in rheinland pfalz hat
sich gut zu klappen in baden württemberg
gab es zwischen cdu und grünen immer mal
ein paar schwierigkeiten natürlich auch
vor dem hintergrund die cdu beim baden
württemberg das regieren eigentlich
sogar einen absoluten mehrheiten gewohnt
und ist jetzt der juniorpartner in einer
koalition mit den grünen und das ist das
was eine partei wie die cdu deswegen
baden württemberg fast immer als
staatspartei verstanden hat auch erst
mal verdauen musste und nach wie vor
mussten gehen
ich sehe hier auch gerade schon
kommentare auf youtube von donato zum
beispiel der oder die meint meine
prognose grün das 40 prozent fdp 11 bis
13 prozent und die bilden dann eine
regierung das wäre aber und vielleicht
können sie das noch mal erklären doch
ein novum warum wäre warum passt das
eigentlich jetzt mal wenn man vom
klischee herr denkt nicht so richtig
zusammen noch nicht mal vom klischee
herrmann beide parteien haben
programmatisch durchaus unterschiedliche
positionen gerade im zentralen politik
hält wie wirtschafts- finanz- sozial-
und verkehrspolitik beispielsweise da
gibt es große programmatische hürden zu
überwinden zwischen grünen und fdp
und wenn man diese hürden überwindet in
form einer koalition muss man
kompromisse machen diese kompromisse
schmecken dann weder dem einen noch dem
anderen flügel innerhalb der partei und
man muss es dann auch den anhängern
verkaufen
warum man eben nicht eins zu eins
regierungsprogramm durchsetzt was man
vorher eigentlich den wählerinnen und
wählern vor der wahl versprochen hat
also das ist eine gewisse schwierigkeit
und eine gewisse hürde jener parteien
programmatisch zusammen liegen desto
einfacher ist im regelfall eine
koalition zu bilden und das ist eine
hürde wenn es um ampel oder um
grün gelbe koalition geht hier gibt es
jetzt einen kommentar der geht in
richtung asd die war ja in der letzten
bundestagswahl extrem wichtig die afd
ich habe ein bisschen das gefühl die hat
an bedeutung zumindest auch in der in
der ganzen diskussion so ein bisschen
verloren also zumindest hat sie sich
medial nicht mehr so präsentieren können
wie in den letzten monaten der kommentar
schreibt oder kommentator kommentatoren
weiß ich nicht die afd bekommt diesmal
weitaus weniger frust weder die gehen
jetzt eher zu grün oder zu einem freien
wähler nichtsdestotrotz gibt es mit
sicherheit 10 bis 13% sie von der
sprache der afg nicht abschrecken lassen
fehlte ergänze ich noch mal tatsächlich
ist aber auch der gerade dieses
aufkommen der freien wähler an einen hof
um das gab es so noch nicht wo kommt
denn dass diese bewegung hat was steckt
dahinter
in den vereinen gelder waren lange zeit
jahrzehntelange eigentlich eine bewegung
die auf lokaler regionaler ebene aktiv
war ist sich dann in manchen
bundesländern entschlossen hatte auf
landesebene anzutreten in rheinland
pfalz dort auch ganz gute chancen haben
in baden-württemberg ist es ein bisschen
komplizierter hier ist der freie wähler
landesverband eigentlich gegen eine
kandidatur auf landesebene gewesen so
dass ich quasi eine andere freie wähler
bewegung die vom bundesverband der trend
geht dazu ermuntert wurde gebildet hat
und bei den landtagswahlen hier antritt
und dort wesentlich weniger chancen hat
also was aber auch spannend wird bei den
kleinen parteien wird das abschneiden
der klima liste sein die sowohl in
rheinland pfalz als auch in baden
württemberg am feld und es wird eben die
frage sein ob sie durchaus über einen
der zwei prozent kommen und was das dann
wiederum für implikationen für die
strategie beispielsweise der grünen hat
in den folgenden wahlen die in diesem
jahr stattfinden
ich stelle es mir ganz neutral fest dass
wir hier relativ viele kommentatoren
haben oder kommentatoren haben die sich
für die afg aussprechen dass teilweise
auch sehr vehement ich würde mal darum
bitten dass das einfache posten des
dateinamens unterbunden wird das müssen
sowieso löschen weil es keine keine
wortmeldung aber da würd mich
interessieren gibt es überhaupt
irgendeine partei die es doch noch
darüber nachdenkt mit der afg vielleicht
doch koalieren
zu wollen oder zumindest die von ihr
sich von ihr dulden zu lassen da gab es
ja durchaus in den ostländern immer mal
wieder denkprozessen 1 in einzelnen
parteiströmungen ob man das vielleicht
doch machen wollen würde
in baden württemberg und rheinland pfalz
für das für keine der parteien auf der
agenda das ist quasi vorab
ausgeschlossen worden und vor dem
hintergrund dass die kfd sich auch in
den letzten monaten und jahren immer
weiter nach rechts entwickelt hat wird
sie sehr wahrscheinlich auch von vielen
parteien in ostdeutschland bei den
kommenden wahlen nämlich als koalitions
oder support partei quasi angesehen
werden da ist die entwicklung relativ
deutlich im prinzip hat sich der der
extremere flügel in der partei
weitgehend durchgesetzt und das sieht
man eigentlich auch relativ schön wenn
man sich die programme und die
presseerklärung der parteien der afc
insbesondere von 2013 an bis heute
anschaut und dem peugeot analysiert es
gibt außerdem relativ viel skepsis
gegenüber briefwahlen hier in den
kommentaren nicht immer einen
exemplarisch raus von uwe auf facebook
das schreibt die rechnen mit 60 prozent
briefwahl
die zeit ist noch nicht gelesen die zahl
ist glaube ich deutlich niedriger aber
trotzdem ein hoher anteil an
briefwählern dabei dieses mal ein schelm
wer böses dabei denkt schreibt und
weiter google müsstet ihr mal dann sieht
man wie einfach der betrug geht
ist es tatsächlich so einfach herr
professor tebus eine briefwahl zu
manipulieren
also man wenn man briefwahlunterlagen
nach hause geschickt bekommen kann man
die ausfüllen geheim sein kreuz machen
seine entscheidung treffen und dann
wieder zurückschicken und es wird unter
natürlich einbeziehung auch der
öffentlichkeit dann ausgezählt also es
gibt keine möglichkeiten hier aktiv zu
betrügen was man natürlich nicht
ausschließen kann ist dass jemand
anderes das kreuz macht für den wähler
oder die wählerinnen diese eigentlich
machen sollte
allerdings muss man unseren eides statt
versichern dass man das dass man diesen
stimmzettel selbst ankreuzt und halt so
was dann
auffliegen würde wenn man sich überhaupt
da machen aber zum beispiel dann so ein
brief von zettel kopieren den aus
abschicken nochmal also dass man quasi
mehrfach wählt das geht ja eigentlich
nicht mehr
manche müssen mal schauen dabei sein das
ist ein zweistufiges verfahren sie
füllen einen wahlschein aus versichern
dort das sieht die person sind die diese
briefwahl beantragt hat und dann bei
legen sie quasi noch einmal in einem
separaten umschlag den stimmzettel
das wird jeweils in dem wahlamt geprüft
und wenn sie einmal gewählt haben sind
sie quasi kann sich durchgestrichen in
der wählerliste und können nicht noch
mal der herr professor debus wir
sprechen uns gleich noch mal wieder wenn
wir so ungefähr wissen wie das in
baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
aussehen könnte muss man ja sagen eben
wegen dieses fragezeichen es mit dem
brief allen bisher aber sage ich erst
mal vielen dank und wir haben nur noch
ein wenig weniger minuten ich denke sie
sind auch ziemlich gespannt darauf fast
zeitgleich beim unter den prognosen
steht
so und jetzt wollen wir noch mal
schalten zu meinem kollegen simon
pfanzelt der iss aus dem zdf wahlstudio
raus und hat sich vor den landtag in
baden württemberg gestellt sieht man bei
dir scheint die lage relativ ruhig im
hintergrund zu sein es gab hier aber
auch immer wieder befürchtungen das ist
zu demonstrationen kommen würde das ist
aber anscheinend nicht der fall
bislang ist das nicht der fall konnten
wir jedenfalls nicht beobachten wir
können nachher gern noch mal auf die
andere seite des schlosses gucken
richtung schlossplatz ist das dann
vielleicht haben sich die menschen
angesammelt aktuell weil sich davon aber
nichts hier ist es ja schon so dass die
anspannung steigt man merkt auch dass
sich die kandidaten beziehungsweise dass
sich die parteiprominenz hier sammelt
hier ist gerade jungen leuten von der
afg vorbeigelaufen auch cem özdemir von
den grünen kam mir vorbei denn es sind
ja wirklich nur noch ganz wenige minuten
bis wir dann wirklich eine prognose
haben und vielleicht können wir die zeit
ein bisschen überbrücken und können euch
zeigen wie wir hier arbeiten wir
arbeiten hier auf einem abgesperrten
areal wenn ihr hier nach hinten guckt da
ist die stuttgarter oper bis dahin ist
das alles abgesperrt und dann wenn wir
hier mal ein bisschen weiter gucken
heute sieht man eben es gibt zelte für
die print journalisten
es gibt übertragungswegen die man sieht
wir haben dann auch ein bisschen
catering hier vor ort damit wir mal
zwischendurch noch was er
können und weitere übertragungswegen
natürlich das ist deshalb gesperrt
worden weil man eben hier die abstände
einhalten will und das klappt im moment
hier ganz gut aber vielleicht ist das
auch der grund dass es für euch jetzt im
fernsehen oder im stream ein bisschen
leer aussieht
ich liebe es gab es da tatsächlich auch
vor allem in stuttgart eben diese
demonstration von querdenken 07 11 das
ganze ist ja ein stuttgart und um
stuttgart herum entstanden
um dies ist ein bisschen ruhig gewonnen
letzten wochen haben die im wahlkampf
überhaupt noch eine rolle gespielt
das war auch unser eindruck dass es da
deutlich ruhiger geworden ist es hat
gestern noch einmal größere
demonstrationen gegeben ja in allen
städten aber im wahlkampf hat das keine
entscheidende rolle gespielt das hat das
haben sich so kleine protestparteien
gebildet die treten hier auch an aber
sieht im grunde keine umfrage dass die
jetzt nennenswert hier stimme
abgegriffen hätten
und auch die afg hat es nach einzahlen
die wir haben nicht geschafft ähnlich zu
mobilisieren wie vor fünf jahren kurz
nach der flüchtlingskrise sondern da
sprechen die umfragen dafür dass dieses
protestpotenzial nicht zur fdp gewandert
ist
ich sehe jetzt hier auch in den
kommentaren tatsächlich wir haben schon
fabry freigesprochen
die ersten befürchtungen von
kommentatoren dass es zu irgendwelchen
manipulationen kommen könnte das ist ja
so ein archiv das kennen wir ja vor
allem aus den usa von der partei um
donald trump herum der die ganze zeit
gesagt hat wenn wir hier nicht gewinnen
dann wurde gefälscht alle gerichte haben
gesagt es gab überhaupt keine anzeichen
dafür
simon ist hier irgendwas bekannt dass es
irgendwelche anzeichen in die richtung
gegeben haben könnte dass es bemühungen
gibt weil die wahlen zu manipulieren
nein überhaupt nicht aber das sind eben
mal so zu sagen diese erzählung die da
aus den usa zu uns herübergeschwappt
sind das würde ich wirklich in die
schublade verschwörungstheorie stecken
also es gibt keine hinweise es gibt
niemanden der sich jetzt auf sage ich
mal amtlicher ebene oder aus beobachter
ebene dar über irgendetwas beschweren
würde also das kann ich überhaupt nicht
erkennen und es ist ja eben auch möglich
einfach dorthin zu gehen und bei der
auszählung dabei zu sein um das zu
kontrollieren sich selbst ein bild zu
machen auch bei der auszählung der
briefwahlstimmen von daher glaube ich
also jeder der skeptisch ist
gehen und gucken wie es da aussieht wird
die skepsis wahrscheinlich relativ
schnell verflogen sein so wir haben
jetzt noch drei minuten dann schalten
wir ins zdf wahlstudio hinter dir um uns
an zugucken wie die prognosen aussehen
glaubst du denn simon das ist da jetzt
doch zu einer überraschung kommen könnte
wir haben ja jetzt gerade schon gehört
mit professor debus im gespräch dass
eventuell ja die grünen mit der fdp
koalieren gab es da tatsächlich aus
seiner perspektive wirklich
annäherungsversuche dieser parteien
es gab zumindest bislang die zahl nicht
die das hergegeben hätten es gibt
annäherungsversuche von der fdp richtung
grüne also die fdp hat in diesem
wahlkampf immer wieder deutlich gemacht
dass sie sich wirklich gut vorstellen
kann mit kretschmann zusammen zu
regieren
kretschmann ist da sehr viel sehr viel
distanzierter der hofft wohl doch eher
das jedenfalls unser eindruck auf eine
fortführung von seiner koalition mit der
cdu spannend wäre das natürlich die
erste koalition wofür grüne und fdp
reicht und was da für eine politik
rauskommen würde also journalistisch
würde man das bestimmt wahnsinnig gerne
begleiten aber sehr wahrscheinlich ist
dass nach meiner einschätzung nicht okay
ich sie schon bei dir das leuchten in
den augen vieler fast so ein bisschen
hin habe ich das gefühl eine frage noch
herr kretschmann musste ja aus dem
wahlkampf ja so ein bisschen
zurücktreten weil seine frau an krebs
erkrankt ist das hat er auch
bekanntgemacht hat gesagt deswegen wird
er keine termine mehr wahrnehmen wie hat
sich das im ball kam es dann tatsächlich
gezeigt also ganz verschwunden ist ja
nicht mehr hat termine gemacht es gab
auch erst letzte woche das waren dann
online formate zb und er ist natürlich
auch immer aufgetreten wenn es darum
ging in diesem bund länder gesprächen
stadt zu finden das war schon so
vielleicht ein hinweis zu kretschmanns
frau hatte gerade mal hat neulich
erzählt dass sie ihre op gut überstanden
hätte und auf dem wege der besserung sei
also insofern gab es dann zum ende
dieses wahlkampfs auch noch bessere
nachrichten
so sieht man ich danke dir für den
moment wir haben nur noch wenige
sekunden bis wir die prognosen bekommen
wir schreiben gleich wieder zu ihr wenn
wir genau wissen was passiert ist aber
schauen jetzt mal ins zdf wahlstudio
wo wir damit rechnen dass in den
nächsten sekunden oder minuten ja quasi
der countdown losgeht in der regie
hörigkeit noch nicht noch nicht noch
nicht
das heißt wir können noch mal kurz
warten wollen bis wir tatsächlich so
weit sind im zdf-studio das ist ja auch
alles die eine sekunden aufgabe die wir
bewältigen müssen ich guck mal kurz in
die kommentare
dann schreibt man auch am rechner dann
wissen wie es weiter geht es mal ein
bisschen gleich vielen dank also hier
wird sich mal wieder beschwert dass wir
kommentare deutschland natürlich löschen
wir kommentare das ist das ganz normal
das macht jeder betreiber von
internetangeboten wenn sie völlig
daneben sind menschen beleidigen oder
dummes zeug ja die posten sind
wahlwerbung löschen wir das haben wir
hier auch gerade geschrieben von die
kollegen die das ganze betreuen
wahlwerbung müssen wir löschen und
natürlich alle möglichen hetze sowas wie
beleidigende e mails etc
also leute das ist keine zensur das ist
einfach kommentar hygiene
wenn ihr eine party macht dann ladet ihr
auch die leute nicht allen die euch
versuchen auf den tisch zu packen
so und jetzt höre ich dass wir ins zdf
wahlstudio rüber schalten können dort
wird es jetzt langsam spannend wir haben
nur noch wenige minuten
ich sehe gerade herr professor korte der
auch eine einschätzung abgibt und ich
würde sagen wir schalten wird vermutlich
merken dass sie kein abonnement hat
automatisch den kanzler zu stellen
sofern ist es vielleicht ein weckruf der
an diesem wochenende ausgeht für die cdu
vielleicht selbst einmal zu definieren
mit welchen themen sie denn auch
mobilisieren wurde also welche führungs
erzählung wollen sie entwickeln mit
welcher person und nicht einfach nur
davon auszugehen dass ein kandidat
automatisch auch kanzler wird
denn in den form fragen musste sie das
ist absehbar schon federn lassen ja
doppelt praktisch weggeschmolzen kann
man sagen einmal der merkel bonus weil
sie nicht mehr zur wahl steht und es
schmilzt eben auch durch die kritik am
code politik und wir haben jetzt vielen
dank professor korte zehn sekunden bis
zur prognose wir werden mit
baden-württemberg beginnen dann direkt
dahinter her rheinland pfalz und dann
schauen wir uns mal an was man daraus
machen kann wir warten auf den gong
die prognose für baden württemberg grüne
31 fünf gewinner grünes rekordergebnis
die cdu 23 prozent verluste das
schlechteste landesergebnis afg 12,5
verluste spd 10,5 auf das verluste
negativrekord im land fdp 11 prozent
gewinne linke 35 ähnlich wie vor fünf
jahren freie wähler 3 prozent und die
anderen zusammen 5 prozent es folgte die
prognose für das land rheinland pfalz
die spd kommt auf 33,5 prozent etwas
verloren aber klar stärkste kraft cdu
25,5 deutliche verluste ihr
schlechtestes landesergebnis afd 10,5
prozent leichte verluste fdp 6,5 ähnlich
wie vor fünf jahren grünen 9,5 das sind
gewinne linke 3,0 wenig veränderungen
freie wähler 5,5 prozent das könnte für
den landtag reichen und die anderen
zusammen 6 prozent ja verheeren fast für
die cdu jetzt gucken wir aber was diese
prognose in sitzverteilung und dann auch
mögliche koalitionen an geht alles von
matthias fornoff bettina wir schauen mal
in die landtage und beginnen in
stuttgart mit der sitzverteilung die
absolute mehrheit liegt dabei 78 sitzen
155 insgesamt da sind ausgleichsmandaten
und übergangs mandate bereits
eingerechnet so dann sehen wir hier die
grünen mit 55 sitzen die cdu mit 41 afd
22 spd 18
und die fdp 19 sitze jetzt ist die frage
wer erreicht diese absolute mehrheit mit
78 sitzen welche partei welche koalition
hier ist die linie dir erreicht oder
überschritten werden muss wir sehen
schon grüne und cdu erreichen das locker
die grünen und spd würden das verfehlen
grüne und fdp erst recht oder nein
ähnlich grüne spd und fdp also das
dreierbündnis das käme auch knapp drüber
es gibt also mindestens zwei
regierungsoptionen in baden württemberg
nach derzeitigen stand
und jetzt schauen wir nach rheinland
pfalz in den landtag von mainz dort
liegt die absolute mehrheit bei 51
sitzen 101 samt da gab es auch noch nie
überhang- und ausgleichsmandaten das ist
also recht safe die spd 37 sitze die cdu
die afg 12 fdp 7 grüne 11 und die freien
wähler wären drin mit sechs sitzen und
wir schauen uns an wer kann mit wem
regieren wer erreicht die 51 als
absolute mehrheit das derzeit amtierende
bündnis von spd grünen und fdp schafft
das mit 55 spd und grüne also rot grün
bleibt runter spd und cdu eine große
koalition wäre deutlich möglich die spd
mit grünen und freien wählern kämen
sogar auch darüber wenn das denn
politisch so überhaupt denkbar wäre und
die cdu mit grünen und fdp auch eine
unwahrscheinliche konstellation würde
die 51 aber auch verfehlen ein wort noch
zur wahlbeteiligung in beiden ländern
bei 65 prozent das ist ziemlich
durchschnittlich für landtagswahlen und
5 prozentpunkte unterhalb der letzten
landtagswahl vor fünf jahren da war die
flüchtlings diskussion das alles
überwältigende und polarisierende thema
also soweit die zahlen aus dem zdf
wahlstudio die ersten prognosen und die
zeigen ja im endeffekt wenn man sich die
regierungsoptionen anguckt herr
professor debus dass die bis jetzt
regierenden koalitionen genau so
weitermachen könnten und das obwohl es
ja viel kritik an der korona politik der
einzelnen landesregierungen auch gibt
woran liegt denn das baden württemberg
ist es nicht überraschend dass denn man
sieht eine mehrheit weiter besteht ist
in die großen koalition beider großer
parteien gewesen
das spannende hier ist nun zu sehen die
cdu schneidet schwach ab sehr schwach
der baden-württembergische verhältnisse
und auch die grünen wenn denn diese
prognose so stimmt beschneiden zwar sehr
gut aber das beste ergebnis was jemand
hatten in baden württemberg aber sind
jetzt so hoch wie das manche umfragen im
vorfeld der wahl gesehen hat also
wenn man das ein bisschen mit
reininterpretiert sind es schon gewisse
denzer spannend und hat jetzt sein zu
sehen ob es sich alternative mehr halten
jeweils die prognose deutlich jetzt erst
mal nicht darauf hin dass es zwei
parteien koalition aus grünen und spd
oder grünen und fdp geben könnte so dass
quasi die alternative in baden
württemberg zu grün schwarz eine
ampelkoalition wäre die aber
programmatisch natürlich einiges über
drücken müsste an distanzen in
rheinland-pfalz sollte vieles darauf hin
dass die ampel wenn die zahlen stimmen
weiter regieren könnte also leichte
dämpfer sagen sie aber nichtsdestotrotz
scheint ja doch die menschen an der
regierung festzuhalten ist dass gerade
in so einer krise so ein bisschen dann
der versucht das man einfach weitermacht
und man weiß ungefähr was man hat im
prinzip ja im prinzip stärken solche
krisen zumindest in der ersten zeit
direkt nach der krise die
regierungsparteien und in dem fall
eigentlich die cdu also etwas wir ja
gesehen hatten in den umfragen auf
bundesebene wir auch auf landesebene war
dass die christdemokraten sehr stark
abschnitten in baden württemberg lagen
die im herbst letzten jahres teilweise
noch vor den grünen
aber dann mit der anwachsenden kritik an
der hand habe der coop 19 pandemie
gebracht dass vor allen dingen die
christdemokraten als die partei die auf
bundesebene zentrale regieren des amtes
kanzler stellen und daraus erklärt sich
jetzt natürlich auch noch in kombination
mit der maske affäre bisher schwache
abschneiden in baden-württemberg und in
rheinland-pfalz für die cdu so wir haben
jetzt hier sehen wir sehen bei zuschauer
der weiß was ist klar dass ihre fragen
muss das jetzt machen
regel 2 studio okay gut dort nicht wir
bleiben doch bei ihnen herr professor
tebus sorry für das leichter chaos ich
habe hier einen sehr aufmerksamen
zuschauer oder zuschauerin auf youtube
der oder die schreibt nämlich auf dem
swr also bei den kollegen vom
saarländischen rundfunk wird die af.de
mit 1 prozent weniger angezeigt statt
des studiums ist rundfunk meine ich
natürlich ist er mit 1 prozent weniger
angezeigt welche prognosen stimmen denn
jetzt nun ja da kann man jetzt sehen
prognosen sind halt prognos
richtig das sind prognosen diesmal sogar
noch stärker mit einer prognose
charakter einfach aufgrund des hohen
briefwähler anteils krefelder kann man
jetzt im wahllokal heute nicht fragen
das müssen die kolleginnen und kollegen
von der forschungsgruppe wahlen oder von
infratest dimap quasi telefonisch in den
wochen vor der wahl machen das heißt wir
sehen hier noch mal einen deutlich
größeren schwankungsbereich als wir den
sonst immer sehen bei prognosen das
heißt hier kann auch das ende ergebnis
nochmal um plus/minus zwei wenn nicht
sogar drei prozentpunkte abweichen von
der prognose
und dass wir quasi unterschied sehen
zwischen den erhebungs instituten das
ist was ganz normales weil er jedes
institut quasi seine eigene simpel
ausgedrückt rezeptur hat wie man
methodisch am besten vorgeht um so eine
prognose zu erstellen andere frage zur
auszählung von annette auf facebook die
möchte nämlich wissen wie ausgezählt
wird werden bei dieser wahl maschinen
dazu genutzt im regelfall wird per hand
ausgezählt was auch eine gewisse
herausforderung im pandemie zeiten ist
deswegen wird es wahrscheinlich auch
noch ein bisschen dauern bis erste
auszählungsergebnisse kommen
wer mal wahlhelfern oder wahlhelfer weiß
wie das abläuft
die stimmzettel werden auf dem großen
tisch geschüttet und dann muss man
irgendwie sortieren und zählen und der
abstandsregeln wird es schwieriger
werden und deswegen wird auch das heute
abend ein bisschen länger dauern bis wir
erste tagen haben auch da gab es jetzt
nochmal befürchtungen in den kommentaren
dass es zumindest dazu manipulationen
kommen könnte
ist es tatsächlich so einfach dann wäre
wenn man wahlhelfer ist aus einem
gültigen stimmzettel einen ungültigen zu
machen wenn man sagt die partei gefällt
mir nicht
nein also wenn man wahlhelferin oder
wahlweise sind muss man natürlich nicht
alleine sondern dann ist damit einer
reihe von
personen die das jeweils unter
einschluss der öffentlichkeit machen das
heißt das kann alles beobachtet und
überprüft werden
und es gibt halt irgendwie stimmzettel
nicht eindeutig gekennzeichnet sind
darüber nachher mit beratung und
schlussendlich werden diese ergebnisse
dann auch noch mal in einem zweiten
schritt überprüft also es gibt hier
wirklich immer mal menschliche fehler
die passieren überall aber
manipulationen ist hier so gut wie nicht
möglich wenn wir noch mal auf die ersten
prognosen schauen die habe ich mir mal
hier auf den rechner gelegt bei uns auf
zdf de kann man sich die auch angucken
da sehen wir hier für 18 uhr baden
württemberg die spd ist quatsch
tschuldigung rheinland pfalz die spd mit
33 5 prozent die cdu mit 25 5% und dann
die partei die in baden württemberg die
stärkste kraft ist mit 95 prozent guckt
man nämlich da in baden württemberg mal
drauf da sind 31,4 prozent für die
grünen
herr professor debus woran liegt das
dass die grüne partei in dem einen
bundesland so stark abschneidet und im
bundesland gleich daneben die liegen ja
nicht weit auseinander so schlecht die
grünen stellen hier seit 2011 mit
winfried kretschmann einen morgen
populären ministerpräsidenten
die grünen waren in baden württemberg
schon immer relativ stark durch das auch
mit zweistelligen ergebnissen was ein
stückweit begründet liegt in ihrer schon
immer relativ pragmatischen
programmatischen ausrichtung das heißt
es sind hier weniger wald links stehend
als in anderen bundesländern als
beispielsweise auch in rheinland pfalz
und hier kommt im hinblick auf die
stärke des wahlergebnisses natürlich
auch ein gewisser amtsinhaber vorteile
zum tragen grünen regieren seit 2011 als
stärkste kraft können den
ministerpräsidenten stellen
und das führt wenn man auch mit
berücksichtigt dass personen und ihre
eigenschaften eine wichtige komponente
sind der mann war verhalten erklären
will
zu so einem hohen wahlergebnis eine
personenwahl steckt natürlich auch immer
parteiwahlen mit drin
da haben wir ja auch mit der
die ministerpräsidentin von rheinland
pfalz malu dreyer eine sehr
charismatische person mit winfried
kretschmann haben ja auch gerade schon
gesagt jemand der durchaus auffällt wenn
ich mir jetzt aber angucke wie die sich
so programmatisch präsentieren auch in
ihren einzelnen bundesländern
dann fällt jedoch auf dass die jeweils
zur bundes partei ja einiges der anwalt
gesagt ich sage mal nicht ganz so großen
mengen haben sie sagten gerade die
grünen in baden württemberg sind nicht
ganz so links die spd ist im vergleich
zu der spd im bund auch etwas
konservativer ist es tatsächlich das
geheimnis dass man sich dort einfach
mehr den ich meinte landes
gepflogenheiten anpasst und deswegen
sind die beiden parteien dort so
erfolgreich das ist durchaus ein grund
den man da heranziehen kann also
parteien wenn sie denn ihren
stimmenanteil maximieren wollen bei
wahlen müssen sich programmatisch so
ausrichten dass sie den nerv der größten
anzahl der wählerinnen und wähler
jeweils treffen das hat die spd in
rheinland pfalz der kurs dauert müssen
erst mal kurz umschalten pressebox
cottbus annalena baerbock von den grünen
ist es dort und hat gerade einen roten
gegeben aber ich glaube wir haben gerade
schon verpasst vielleicht können wegen
gleich nochmal aufrufen
ich frage mal kurz in die regie ja also
da waren wir jetzt zu spät damit den
o-ton von den grünen aber wir werden ihn
mit sicherheit gleich nochmal gleich
nochmal nachliefern um zu hören was die
grünen ja zu ihrem erfolg in baden
württemberg zu sagen haben genau wir
haben darüber gesprochen wie wichtig
quasi diese programmatik ist die cdu in
beiden ländern eigentlich auch ja
jahrelang ich habe mir hier so auch so
eine grafik bei uns auffliegen können
mal kurz auf meinen rechner nochmal
schalten zum beispiel die cdu in
rheinland pfalz werden wir uns da die
wahl ergebnisse angucken hat
jahrzehntelang tatsächlich die regierung
gestellt also dass man immer vor der spd
ist gab mal eine leichte annäherung 163
und seit 1987 ist die cdu in
rheinland-pfalz auf dem absteigenden ast
und ähnlich sieht das in baden
württemberg aus wenn man einmal weiter
klickt hier die baden in baden
württemberg wo die cdu immer führende
kraft mit jahr 1976 über 50 prozent
dann fiel sie auf 40 prozent
1992 und dann ging es stetig bergab und
seit 2011 wie gesagt ist er kretschmann
an der macht was ist denn da passiert
herr professor debus mit der cdu das ist
in beiden ländern ja so bergab gegangen
ist für die partei
die regierungswechsel in rheinland pfalz
von der cdu der spd sie hat mir gerade
gesagt die cdu dominierte rheinland
pfalz von staatsgründung bis zur
landtagswahl 91 91 passierte eine
landtagswahl im kontext der zeit nach
der deutschen wiedervereinigung wo die
bundesregierung damals unpopulärer weise
steuern erhöht das brachte die spd zum
ersten mal in rheinland pfalz nach vorne
und die spd hatte seit eben geschafft
daran anhalts bei landtagswahlen immer
wieder zu gewinnen in koalition auch mit
der fdp überraschenderweise für einen
längeren zeitraum in den 90er und frühen
nullerjahren in baden württemberg war
ein faktor der die grünen auch mit nach
vorne gebracht hatte schlicht mehr
greifen die kombination aus der
diskussion um stuttgart 21 und dem
fukushima-desaster dass nur wenige tage
vor der 2011er landtagswahl stattfand
das brachte das thema umweltschutz und
energiepolitik und atomkraft auch die
agenda und half den grünen 2011
zweitstärkste kraft zu werden so dass
ich mir keinen kretschmann den
ministerpräsidenten in einer grün-roten
koalition stellen konnten aus dieser
lage heraus davon profitieren die grünen
in baden württemberg noch immer so ich
guck mal kurz in die kommentare hier
gibt es bis ein bisschen hennes für
unser regie chaos gerade tut mir leid
dass du das hier so ein bisschen gerade
haben ist es eine live sendung und wir
versuchen parallel noch ein auge darauf
zu haben was in berlin respektive
stuttgart gerade passiert da kann das
schon mal daneben gehen weil wir einfach
jetzt auch viele informationen von
vielen seiten bekommen diese versuchen
zu einer sendung zusammen zu führen so
das ganze was heißt denn das ganze jetzt
dieses wahlergebnis für die grünen im
bund professor debus also das ist ja im
endeffekt bleibt winfried kretschmann
eine starke macht unten in baden
württemberg im süden können davon die
grünen dem bund profitieren haben sie
das bis jetzt überhaupt schon
sie haben insofern davon profitiert als
das bei der öffentlich
bundesweit gezeigt hat die grünen können
nicht nur regieren sondern sie können
auch eine regierung anführen und das
über mittlerweile zwei
legislaturperioden hinweg in hinblick
auf die diskussionen die
regierungsfähigkeit ist das natürlich
ein klares signal die frage ist
natürlich auch mein bundesweit in der
lage sein wird stärker zu werden als die
spd beispielsweise und dann einen
möglichen grüner ampel anführen zu
können
also das ist die diskussion die sich in
den nächsten wochen zeigen wird auch in
der frage ob die grünen dann einen
kanzlerkandidaten oder eine
kanzlerkandidatin nominiert das heißt
jetzt rückschlüsse zu ziehen aus der
stärke in baden württemberg kann
natürlich auch ein bisschen in die irre
führen weil die lager auf bundesebene
wiederum der andere ist und wir sehen ja
in rheinland-pfalz schneiden die grünen
zwar gut ab liegen aber bei 110 prozent
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger und das
ist natürlich weiter von entwickelten
entfernt die position eines kanzler
stellen zu können
professor der bus vielen dank bis
hierhin für ihre einschätzungen zu
diesen ersten prognosen und wir gehen
jetzt tatsächlich rüber als wahlstudio
dann hätte man sie kein weniger einer
für die grüne partei natürlich ist
winfried kretschmann eine herausragende
politische persönlichkeit aber er hat im
wahlkampf deutlich die grünen themen
nach vorne gestellt
es war ein gemeinsamer wahlkampf und
winfried kretschmann ist grüner durch
und durch also ohne seine herausragende
personen schmälern zu wollen nein das
ist ein großer grüner wahlsieg heute
abend und das heißt also so ein erfolg
kann ich nur winfried kretschmann
sondern das könnte robert habeck auch
wir nehmen den erfolg als rückenwind für
den bund und für den bundestagswahlkampf
und dann werden wir geschlossen und
optimistisch einen guten erfolg im
september einfahren
rückenwind für den bundestag was lernen
sie aus rheinland pfalz dort ist der
erfolg wesentlich weniger glänzend für
die grünen aber es könnte dort
weitergehen mit der ampel-koalition
unter spd-führung ist die ampel jetzt
tatsächlich haben das gerade schon von
der spd gehört eine option für die
grünen im bundestagswahlkampf kämpfen
werden
erst einmal ist hervorzuheben auch
gerade mit blick auf rheinland pfalz das
in krisenzeiten
die haben wir ja ohne frage in der mitte
pandemie die grünen gewinnen können also
dass wir auch unterschiedlichsten
gesellschaftlichen bedingungen große
erfolge gute erfolge einfahren können da
muss man erst mal einen dicken strich
darunter ziehen und umgekehrt muss man
sagen dass die union das vertrauen die
cdu das vertrauen nicht jedenfalls nicht
automatisch gewinnen kann
insofern ist das ein starkes mandat
zukunft zu gestalten und in die
regierung zu gehen wir werden den beiden
regierungen denke ich beteiligt sein
und in beiden ländern wird jetzt
verhandelt in sondiert werden in
rheinland pfalz vermutlich läuft es auf
eine ampel zu in baden württemberg wird
entlang der stärke der fraktionen mit
den anderen parteien gesprochen und
winfried kretschmann hat gesagt drei
themen sind entscheidend klimaschutz
klimaschutz klimaschutz und dann werden
wir gucken mit welchen parteien am
meisten umsetzbar ist
aber die frage ist ja herr beck werden
sie nicht farbe bekennen müssen in
dieser gretchenfrage geradezu für die
grünen wie hältst du es mit den
schwarzen wäre es mit den roten oder den
linken das farbe bekennen heißt denn
lang der inhalte am meisten umsetzen so
stark werden wie es geht das gilt für
die länder das gilt für den bund so
stark werden wie es geht damit eine
machtoption herstellen und dann schauen
in den gesprächen welche partei was
umsetzen will und umsetzen kann
mit blick auf baden württemberg
beispielsweise muss man sagen dass die
fdp im klimaschutz noch mehr bremst als
die union wir werden gucken wie sich das
in den gesprächen entwickelt aber ein
automatismus den kann es nicht geben das
gilt auch für den bund der wahlabend
zeigt er dass verschiedene
regierungsoptionen möglich sind das kann
man bedauern dass es quasi uneindeutig
ist man kann es aber auch begrüßen und
sagen jede partei für sich das beste
angebot die besten personen nach vorne
und dann gucken wir was mal rauskommt
und so wollen wir es halten sagt robert
habeck der vorsitzende der grünen vielen
dank nach berlin
und jetzt schauen wir mal auf die
reaktion bei der cdu nämlich den
generalsekretären sie mir ja meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren um es in
aller klarheit zu sagen das ist heute
kein guter wahlabend für die cdu
werden uns bei den landtagswahlen in
baden württemberg und rheinland pfalz
andere werden uns bessere ergebnisse
gewünscht trotzdem zunächst einmal der
dank aber an die wählerinnen und wähler
die uns an diesem heutigen tag und in
den vergangenen wochen bei den briefen
ihr vertrauen ausgesprochen haben und
ich bedanke mich ganz ausdrücklich
insbesondere bei susanne eisenmann und
christian baldauf für ihren engagierten
einsatz und natürlich auch bei allen
kandidatinnen und kandidaten bei diesen
wahlen in rheinland pfalz in baden
württemberg aber auch bei den
kommunalwahlen in hessen sagt der
cdu-generalsekretär zehn jahre so und
jetzt können wir höhere ich tatsächlich
mal auf die fdp schauen die eigentlich
einen ganz guten abend erwischt hat in
baden württemberg in der prognose eines
der besten ergebnisse der letzten
jahrzehnte kann man schon sagen und in
rheinland-pfalz immerhin das ergebnis
mit 6,5 wie vor fünf jahren dann noch
mal erreicht eva schiller hat hier in
baden württemberg sowie sondern habe gut
zehn jahren einmal cdu einmal die grünen
herr professor debus
politikwissenschaftler von der uni haben
mannheim ist bei uns und beantwortet
unsere fragen zu diesen ganzen
konglomerat eine sache ist nicht
aufgefallen und die würde ich gerne mit
ihnen mal durchgehen
er habe gerade noch mal darauf ja betont
wie wichtig der klimaschutz für die
grünen ist auch für den
ministerpräsidenten von baden
württemberg den bisherigen und
wahrscheinlich auch zukünftigen winfried
kretschmann aber ist es tatsächlich so
dass man jetzt attestieren kann die
grünen haben in baden württemberg was
das thema angeht richtig was bewegt sie
haben das natürlich angestoßen und
versuchte das thema zu bewegen denken
sie beispielsweise an diskussionen um
feinstaub grenzwerte oder
infrastrukturprojekte oder tempolimits
allerdings reagieren sie in einer
koalition mit der cdu
und hier müssen kompromisse eingegangen
werden
mit dementsprechend konnten sie
natürlich bei weitem nicht alles das
umsetzen was ich auch ursprünglich mal
versprochen oder gefordert haben was im
prinzip das dilemma von dem regieren in
koalitionsregierung
man möchte natürlich eigentlich 100
prozent des wahlprogramms umsetzen weil
man dann bei den nächsten wahlen
natürlich besser den wählerinnen und
wählern gegenüber treten kann aber in
koalition muss man kompromisse eingehen
und damit inhaltlicher abstriche machen
und je weiter die koalitionspartner
auseinander stehen desto größer sind die
kompromisse und gerade in fragen von
umwelt energie verkehrspolitik hat die
cdu teilweise auch durchaus anderer
auffassung so dass hier keine rein grüne
politik durchgesetzt werden konnte
professor debus vielen dank bis hierhin
wir sprechen nachher nochmal weiter wenn
wir weitere stimmen aus der politik
zusammen haben oder vielleicht neue
prognosen oder vielleicht sogar schon
hochrechnungen ist hier aber erstmal
vielen dank und ich schalte zu meiner
kollegin andrea maurer ins
hauptstadtstudio in berlin vom zdf hallo
adria
da wirst du wieder es hat er gerade
gesehen
die cdu hat ganz schön einbüßen müssen
wohl nach unseren prognosen also minus
4,5 prozent in baden württemberg
was heißt das jetzt für die bundes union
ja also es sind ja erst mal nur
prognosen aber klar es zeichnet sich ab
dass möglicherweise die cdu in baden
württemberg einem stammland muss man ja
mal sagen der cdu tatsächlich das
schlechteste ergebnis ihrer geschichte
einfahren könnte und das ist für die
union natürlich fauzy merck hat das ja
gesagt das ist kein guter kein guter
abend
und tatsächlich das jetzt diese option
ampel auch in baden württemberg im raum
steht denke ich dass es auch ja dass die
cdu im grunde genommen dass es
vielleicht so zu sagen dass angst
szenario dieser partei das ist eben die
fortsetzung der ampel in rheinland pfalz
geben wird möglicherweise und in baden
württemberg auch eine ampel käme das ist
dann einfach tatsächlich so dass es die
machtoptionen auch im bund noch mal
erweitert und sozusagen auch für die
bundestagswahl sozusagen eine neue
alternative ins spiel bringt und armin
laschet selbst hat mal gesagt ja dann
ist sozusagen die spd für das soziale
zuständig in so einer koalition die
grünen sind für das ökologische
zuständig und die fdp ist für das
ökonomische zuständig und wo bleiben
dann wir
und er verweist eben auch auf rändern
falls das hat herr debus ja auch gesagt
wo seit 30 jahren die spd eben mit gelb
und in gelben und also rot-gelben
rot-grünen konstellation in ampere
konzentration oder alleine regiert und
die cdu im gründer seit 30 jahren nicht
mehr in der regierung ist und das ist
sozusagen tatsächlich ein angst szenario
das man in der union wohl hat gibt es ja
auch ein kommentar dazu von einem user
oder userin deren liegt nämlich
überhaupt nicht aussprechen kann weil es
nur noch zeichen sind aber ampel
regierung in baku wäre doch cool starkes
signal für den bund jetzt gucken wir mal
auf die anderen parteien wie die
abgeschnitten haben also fdp und hfd
liegen in beiden bundesländern wenn ich
das richtig im kopf habe einigermaßen
mit ähnlichen ergebnissen also die fdp
11 prozent prognose in baden württemberg
kfd 12,5 prozent und in rheinland-pfalz
schaue ich noch mal die afg bei 10,5
prozent die fdp da ist sie deutlich
schwächer 65 prozent gab es denn jetzt
schon irgendwelche reaktionen aus diesen
beiden parteilager dann hast du schon
was mitbekommen
also da ich ja sozusagen die ganze zeit
unser programm gucke ich muss ich dir
sagen dass ich da sozusagen in dieser
verwirrung um den werbern so ein
bisschen hängen geblieben bin
deswegen kann ich es nicht genau sagen
aber was ich dir sagen kann ist dass es
tatsächlich so zusagen von seiten der
fdp und das ist ja auch ganz interessant
auch im hinblick auf baden württemberg
um werbung versuche kann man vielleicht
sagen in richtung grünen gab also der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer marco
buschmann der hatte
letzte woche gepostet citrus koalition
also grüne und gelbe das wäre doch
irgendwie ein ende gysi energetisierung
der cocktail und das heißt ja die grünen
sind tatsächlich und vielleicht zeigt
dass oder sie vielleicht sind sie
diejenigen die gerade am umworben ssten
sind und das wird auf jeden fall
interessant auch jetzt was im zuge
dieser wahl dieser beiden beinen heute
eben für koalitionen rauskommen so du
hast gerade gesagt den o-ton von
annalena baerbock von den grünen denen
haben wir jetzt hier in unserem spiel
knapp verpasst deswegen haben wir
natürlich aufgezeichnet und können jetzt
noch mal einspielen wollen uns natürlich
über dieses große wahlergebnisse gerade
in baden württemberg zum dritten mal in
folge haben grüne in baden württemberg
zugelegt sind wieder stärkste kraft
geworden und auch in rheinland pfalz
konnten wir deutlich unsere stimmen
verdoppeln
ich freue mich wahnsinnig darüber dass
malu dreyer gewonnen hat sie ist für
mich die siegerin des abends wenn man
überlegt vor ein paar wochen noch lagen
wir deutlich hinter der union in
rheinland pfalz und sie hat gekämpft sie
hat gezeigt dass sie als
ministerpräsidentin in der lage ist mit
einem guten krisen-management rheinland
pfalz auch nach vorne zu bringen
das haben die wählerinnen und wähler
honoriert und wir sehen da wo die spd
regiert wo sie verantwortung trägt da
gewinnt sie auch das vertrauen der
menschen
soweit also die stimmen aus der
bundespolitik und ich gebe jetzt mal
nach stuttgart zu meinem kollegen simon
pfanzelt denn der steht dort mit dem
politikwissenschaftler korte und ich
immer gespannt was er zu diesem
wahlergebnis nur dazu diesen prognosen
zu sagen hat ja herr korte ist
dankenswerterweise herausbekommen aus
dem zdf wahlstudio wo es hier wirklich
ein bisschen frisch geworden ist in
stuttgart konnte wie fällt ihr
zwischenfazit aus bei dieser
landtagswahl sehr für die dynamik drin
wir konnten das wir im vorfeld so nicht
wissen weil in der distanz demokratie zu
wählen was außer alltägliches ist es
gibt keine vergleichsmaßstäbe sowohl was
die mobilisierung anbelangt als auch
verziehen
meine technik jetzt umfragen technisch
etwas zu bruch sie prognostizieren für
den heutigen tag insofern
gibt es auch weitere überraschungen
nämlich mal
aber es gibt tendenzen insbesondere wenn
man auf die cdu guckt das sind schon
katastrophale ergebnisse muss man sagen
ja manchmal schon fast demütigend für
die betroffenen akteure im vorfeld sah
es anders aus offenbar haben die wenigen
fehler die es gab noch mal zum anlass
genommen um auch diese masken affäre mit
einzubringen in der wählervotum anders
ist es nicht zu erklären aber die union
hat praktisch ein abschmelzen vor sich
im bundestagswahlkampf einmal durch den
merkel bonus der einfach schwindet weil
sie nicht mehr antritt und jetzt durch
die kritik an der konkreten corona
politik all das kommt am heutigen tag
zusammen bei den grünen sehen wir gute
ergebnisse vor allem in baden
württemberg aber auch in rheinland pfalz
ist das ein signal mit dem man dann auch
in dieses superwahljahr gehen kann auch
in richtung bundestagswahl
ja die grünen haben zulauf aus
verschiedenen richtungen einmal
natürlich als kompetenzzentrum für
umwelt und klima aber auch diese still
gestellte zeit in der wir uns befinden
der umgang mit schonenden ressourcen
er macht viele wähler der grünen doch
nachdenklich und sie haben zu laufen
einfach zu tun
dieses thema bekommen dass wir nicht her
der natur sind sondern vielleicht das
virus stärker sein könnte also löst das
viel nachdenklichkeit zusätzlich aus es
kommt die zu dass sie in führungs- und
kommunikations war sehr modern für ein
bildungsbürger des tnt argumentieren und
das führt natürlich zu einer faszination
zu und waldtage dass dieses corona thema
irgendwie das wichtigste war für die
wählerinnen und wähler das haben wir in
den umfragen vorhergesehen die grünen
haben sie profitiert hat noch jemand
profitiert oder wer hat gar nicht
profitiert das weil die parteien der
mitte erstmal haben schon auch
profitiert kann man sagen dass bekannte
ist natürlich zentraler gewählt worden
als dass unbekannte das virus hat alles
bestimmt die themen die akteure die
mobilisierung auch den
parteienwettbewerb das die ard als
extreme partei nicht so groß wie beim
letzten mal auch damit zusammen dass sie
eben kein zukunftsgerichtet zu
programmen angeboten hat zum thema nach
corona
insofern
die werte kommt die sie beim letzten mal
erreicht wir haben vorher eine user
frage da ging es darum ob es denkbar
wäre eine grüne gelbe koalition zu
machen hier in baden württemberg die
zahlen geben das aktuell nicht hier
nicht musste ich kurz unterbrechen das
tut mir leid weil wir haben jetzt die
ministerpräsidenten von rheinland-pfalz
malu dreyer im o ton wir schalten über
das zdf-studio wir machen weiter mit
professor de bus der uns hoffentlich
auch auf der anderen leitung vorliegt
dann müssen wir mal kurz rüber switchen
sorry für das durcheinander ist einem
wahlabend einfach so das sind doch noch
eine riesen muss man sagen deswegen
passiert das manchmal da ist der
professor der wussten ich habe hier eine
frage die finde ich wirklich gut weil
sie ganz einfach und simpel ist die so
einfach und sind mit fragen muss man ja
manchmal auch beantworten nämlich wenn
wir einmal auf meinen rechner schalten
von oikos kreativ studio wer gewinnt
eigentlich wenn zwei gleich starke
parteien am ende rauskommen wenn man
muss es dann vor dem hintergrund der
ergebnisse vom quasi einmal von vor fünf
jahren sehen
je nachdem wer da die gut abgeschnitten
hat bzw
vor dem hintergrund wie geben fragen
natürlich aussehen also wurde waren also
wenn man jetzt hier die ergebnisse für
grüne und cdu sich anschaut in baden
württemberg die waren bei der letzten
wahl noch halbwegs gleich auf und nun
sind die grünen deutlich stärker als die
christdemokraten dann könnte man sagen
die grünen haben sind natürlich gestärkt
aus dieser wahl hervorgegangen werden
die christdemokraten als kleiner
koalitionspartner das nicht sind uns in
der klare wahlsieger und noch dazu gibt
es quasi die tradition oder die regel
die informelle regel die stärkste
fraktion im parlament beginnt die
sondierungsgespräche
das heißt andere vertreterin vertreter
von parteien ein
über eine künftige mehrheit
koalitionsmehrheit zu sprechen
das bringt die grünen und die spd in
rheinland pfalz
dann in eine besonders gute agenda
sitzungs lage eine weitere finde ich
auch sehr gute und sehr einfache frage
von feierabend 1 auf youtube was macht
eigentlich die partei die grünen anders
was machen die anders als die anderen
parteien
wenn wir jetzt mal auf die
unterschiedlichen bundesländer gucken
wenn die grünen das hat karl rudolf
korte ja eben auch schon angedeutet
profitieren stark davon dass hier ein
thema momentan auf der agenda haben in
form von der hohen relevanz von
klimapolitik umweltpolitik
energiepolitik wo viele wählerinnen und
wähler die grünen als die parteien
finden die das problem am ehesten lösen
kann und das ist eine zentrale
komponente auch in der erklärung von
wahlverhalten
das macht die grünen momentan nicht nur
in deutschland oder in den deutschen
bundesländern sondern auch in vielen
anderen europäischen staaten attraktiv
und bringt ihnen zulauf wählerinnen und
wähler ebene so ich schaue jetzt mal ob
ich für sie noch einige fragen hier habe
gibt es schon was zur wahlbeteiligung
ist eine gute frage da habe ich noch
nichts gehört wissen sieht da schon mehr
auch nur aus den zahlen die ich hier
sehe wenn ich das richtig noch in
erinnerung haben lag das bei über 60
prozent in baden württemberg also jetzt
nicht super hoch aber für landtagswahlen
gerade in pandemie bedingungen ist das
jetzt kein schlechter wert
wie gesagt man muss das allerdings alles
ein bisschen immer noch mit vorsicht
genießen wir sind schätzung die hier
eintreffen
und wenn sie weiß man erst quasi wenn
einiges ausgezählt ist wie es dann
tatsächlich auch aussieht wissen wir
dann schon genauso viele briefwähler
tatsächlich diesmal dabei waren auch nur
aus schätzungen das was ich in der
letzten woche noch gehört hatte von
kolleginnen und kollegen war dass wir
durchaus mit 50 60 prozent briefwähler
rechnen können baden württemberg mit
mehr als in rheinland pfalz bei den
letzten beiden waren schon 20 bis 30
prozent also das ist das was wir auch im
prinzip in den letzten jahren schon
immer sehen der briefwähler anteil
steigt kontinuierlich an
der war früher sehr niedrig und in den
letzten jahren oder letzten 10 15 jahren
gibt es immer mehr bürgerinnen und
bürger die von dieser option der
briefwahl gebrauch machen für alle die
jetzt gerade erst dazu schalten aber
noch nicht so richtig
einen durchblick haben wäre jetzt
eigentlich bei den landtagswahlen in
rheinland-pfalz und in baden-württemberg
wie abgeschnitten haben könnte muss man
ja immer noch sagen wir reden immer noch
über prognosen und noch nicht über
hochrechnungen und erst recht nicht über
amtliche endergebnis die kommen wir
immer erst viel später am abend oder
manchmal am frühen morgen schalten wir
noch mal auf meinen rechner auf unsere
prognose vom zdf für also von der
forschungsgruppe wahlen für das zdf hier
fangen an den rheinland pfalz die
prognose 18 uhr sagt in prozent 33,5
prozent für die spd für die amtierende
ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer 25,5
prozent für die cdu die afg kommt als
drittstärkste kraft auf 10,5 prozent die
fdp auf 6,5 prozent
und dann kommen die grünen mit 9,5
prozent die linke wird mit bis jetzt
drei prozent den einzug in das
landesparlament verpassen aber die
freien wähler könnten rein kommen
und wenn wir eine slide weitergehen
sehen wir hier
die cdu hat sehr deutlich verlorenen
rheinland pfalz minus 6,3 prozent
stimmen im gegensatz zur wahl 2016
die spd musste auch 2,7 prozent der
stimmen abgeben die fdp ebenso 2,1
prozent die fdp ein bisschen gewinnen
können 0,3 prozent nach unserer prognose
die grünen dafür die deutlichen gewinne
in rheinland pfalz mit plus 4,2 prozent
genau wie die freien wähler mit plus 3,3
prozent das heißt da hat sich doch
deutlich was bewegt und wenn wir auf die
sitzverteilung gucken dann sehen wir die
stärkste kraft ist natürlich dieses spd
mit 37 sitzen die cdu kriegt 28 sitze
die afg 12 dahinter gleicht die grünen
mit 11 sitzen die spd die fdp würde
siebensitzer kriegen nach dieser
prognose und die freien wähler sechs das
ganze heißt dann wenn wir auf die
möglichen koalitionen mal gucken wir
haben in rheinland-pfalz 101
parlamentssitze im landtag bei 51 ist
damit also die absolute mehrheit
erreicht das reicht zum regieren und da
haben wir derzeit 12 34 mögliche
koalitionen also einmal wäre dann
möglich eine koalition aus spd grünen
und fdp die hürden auf
55 prozent kommen und das ist bei 45
sitze kommen und das ist tatsächlich die
ampel koalition die wir jetzt schon die
letzten fünf jahre hatten möglich wäre
aber auch eine koalition aus spd und
union also eine große koalition die
würden zusammen auf satte 65 sitze
kommen
denkbar aber auch eine koalition aus spd
grünen und fdp ist das genau die story
die haben wir da eine freie wähler sorry
die fdp und die freien wähler kann man
nicht so gut sehen unterscheiden also
spd grüne und freie wähler die hätten
einen sitz weniger als die ampel
koalition die wir bis jetzt hatten also
54 sitze oder auch möglich cdu grüne und
freie wähler so wenn wir jetzt mal über
diese möglichen koalition sprechen herr
professor debus schauen wir mal unten an
wie wahrscheinlich ist dann so eine
koalition aus der union den grünen der
fdp und den freien wählern aber die
frage die sich stellt ist warum sollten
die grünen und die fdp aus der koalition
der momentan bestehenden koalition mit
den sozialdemokraten ausscheiden
die ja gut funktioniert und wo die
parteien vor der wahl ja auch mehr oder
weniger einmal anklingen lassen dass sie
auch gerne weiterführen würden
dementsprechend ist es eher
unwahrscheinlich auch wenn man mal mit
einbezieht es werden nicht nur drei
parteien sondern vier parteien mit denen
man kompromisse bilden müsste und das
normalen zusammenleben es ist immer
komplizierter sich auf kompromisse zu
einigen je höher die anzahl der personen
ist mit denen man quasi sich einigen
muss dementsprechend sind auch in der
regierungsbildung koalition er dann
wahrscheinlich wenn es weniger akteure
betrifft also das wäre dann eine
koalition aus zum beispiel wie wir es
jetzt schon haben spd grünen und fdp
oder spd grünen und den freien wählern
wir haben mittlerweile ein o-ton
vorliegen herr professor debus von malu
dreyer noch bisherige
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland pfalz
und wahrscheinlich auch die zukünftige
wie hört mal rein es ist eine
bestätigung dafür dass die spd eine gut
aufgestellte partei ist und wir mit all
unseren kollegen kollegen in der partei
gekämpft haben und deshalb ist heute
einfach nur
schön dass wir so klar an der spitze
stehen und das ziel erreicht haben
nämlich mit abstand die stärkste partei
wieder zu sein und einen klaren
regierungsauftrag zu haben ja also
freude trotz dieser verluste finden sie
das gerechtfertigt gegeben wo die
sozialdemokraten auf bundesebene stehen
nämlich immer noch bei werten von um die
15 prozent teilweise sogar ein bisschen
weniger ist das natürlich ein großer
erfolg für die spd nach anderen teils
auch vor dem hintergrund dass sich das
parteiensystem in der hand als auch
durchaus aufgefächert hat das ist das
was wir noch nicht so ganz angesprochen
haben die tatsache dass eine weitere
partei ins parlament einzieht nämlich
die freien wähler oder möglicherweise
einzieht ist schon auch eine
herausforderung bedeuten dann brechen
wir gehen ins studio zurück denn dort
passieren jetzt die neuesten prognosen
wir schaffen die linke 3,4 wäre damit
nicht im landtag von stuttgart vertreten
plus 0,5 und die freien wähler mit drei
prozent auch darunter
jetzt schauen wir mal was das heissen
würde fürs regieren im stuttgarter
landtag absolute mehrheit liegt derzeit
bei 78 sitzen grüne und cdu die
amtierende regierung würde das sicher
schaffen mit 94 grüne und spd würde es
deutlich nicht schaffen da fehlen fünf
sitze 73 grüne und fdp dafür in vier
sitze mit 74 grüne spd und fdp
das wäre die alternative zu schwarz grün
zu grün schwarz das hat auch eine
mehrheit in baden württemberg jetzt weiß
ich gar nicht haben
rheinland pfalz auch schon nein kommt
später na gut das war also die
hochrechnungen für baden württemberg
herzlichen dank matthias und in berlin
bin ich jetzt verbunden mit dem
fdp-vorsitzenden höre ich ja christian
lindner nannte lindner
guten abend frau schausten hinter das
ist ein guter wahlabend für sie und die
fdp wir haben es gerade gehört die erste
hochrechnung in baden württemberg 11,4
prozent dass es eines der besten
ergebnisse der letzten jahrzehnte kann
man schon sagen in rheinland pfalz
werden sie vermutlich noch gebraucht für
die bildung einer ampel regierung welche
schlüsse ziehen sie jetzt aus diesem
wahlabend
die beginnende bundestagswahl den
wahlkampf es ist ein guter auftakt in
das wahljahr wir freuen uns über
wachsenden zuspruch in baden württemberg
sie haben es gesagt eines der besten
wahlergebnisse der letzten jahrzehnte
zweistelligkeit und den rheinland pfalz
so wie es aussieht zum ersten mal in
unserer geschichte wurde dort eine ampel
koalition von den wählerinnen und
wählern bestätigt also ein guter auftakt
für das jahr
wir nehmen das als ein auftrag weiter
eigenständig unsere politische rolle zu
definieren in der sache bei der pandemie
politik etwa auf freiheit zu achten
in der wirtschaftspolitik nicht nur auf
burak bürokratismus zu setzen sondern
auch an die freiheit dort zu denken also
diesen eigenständigen kurs setzen wir
weiter fort herr lindner die ampel in
rheinland-pfalz tatsächlich wieder
gewählt sie haben darauf hingewiesen
jetzt hatte ich sie eigentlich immer so
verstanden dass beispiel
nordrhein-westfalen sich die fdp doch
eher an der seite der cdu sieht ihr
kollege in baden württemberg bietet sich
jetzt dem grünen ministerpräsidenten
durchaus an in rheinland-pfalz eben
stehen die zeichen auf fortsetzung der
ampel ist die fdp die jetzt so ein
bisschen auf ampel kurs auf will's mal
überspitzt sagen rot grünem kuschelkurs
nein das sind wir ganz sicher nicht bei
jeder wahl nach jeder wahl entscheiden
wir nach gesprächen ob gutes für das
lands bewirkt werden kann oder nicht
entscheidend sind da die inhalte mit der
fdp wird es mit sicherheit keinen
linksruck geben mit der fdp wird es eher
niedrigere als höhere steuern geben kein
verbot des dieselmotors oder des
einfamilienhauses wie manche grünen das
fordern sondern er den menschen
erleichtern ihr leben zu führen in
eigentum zu kommen mobil zu bleiben also
wir entscheiden es an inhalten und wie
sie wissen wenn die inhalte nicht
stimmen dann nehmen wir uns sogar die
freiheit mal nein zu sagen
dann erinnern sie damit jetzt gerade an
die geplatzten jamaica verhandlungen
beim letzten mal dann hieße das doch
jetzt vielleicht bei bei jamaika für die
fdp hallo ampel
nein ich sage nochmal es entscheidet
sich an inhalten und im bund sind ja
sozialdemokraten und grüne wesentlich
weiter links der mitte als sie das in
baden württemberg und rheinland pfalz
sind
ich will überhaupt gar nicht jetzt schon
bevor gewählt worden ist irgendetwas
ausschließen ohne dass man wahlprogramme
kennt aber ich sage es nochmal frau
schausten
wir machen das an ihn halten fest und
wenn man sich die inhalte an sieht trotz
einer gewissen ambitionslose kite bei
der union die ich beklage und trotz der
differenzen jetzt in der pandemie
politik in der sache inhaltlich steht
uns die union von den anderen parteien
noch am nächsten
das heißt aber zunächst einmal nichts
denn bei der letzten wahl 2017 darauf
hatte ich hingewiesen ist ein jamaika
bündnis nicht an den grünen gescheitert
sondern an der merkel cdu in diesem jahr
werden die karten neu gemischt
bekanntlich tritt frau merkel ja nicht
noch einmal an
es war christian lindner der
fdp-vorsitzende herzlichen dank nach
berlin und jetzt haben wir interessante
analyse daten nämlich wie nach
altersgruppen gewählt worden ist ja
bettina in der tat es gibt die ersten
wahltags befragungsergebnisse unsere
forschungsgruppe wahlen befragten
jeweils 160 wahllokalen in beiden
ländern die wählerinnen und wähler ist
natürlich anonym
aber daraus lassen sich strukturen
ableiten und wir schauen mal hier auf
die spd wer wählte die spd in
rheinland-pfalz nach alter die spd hat
insgesamt etwas verloren die verluste
besonders bei den unter 30 jährigen
sie ist aber in allen altersgruppen
stärkste partei
und das ist hier das ist das
interessanteste an dieser grafik bei den
über 60-jährigen holt sie 41 prozent
legt sogar noch etwas zu das ist
eigentlich eine domäne der cdu jetzt
schauen wir mal auf die grünen in
rheinland pfalz auch nach alter da sehen
wir das klassische bild für die grünen
bei den unter 30-jährigen bärenstark 18
prozent nochmals zugelegt neun punkte
bei den mittleren altersgruppen gut und
bei den über 60 jährigen sind es dann
gerade noch 5
jetzt wird es aber spannend das ist
rheinland-pfalz das ist das klassische
grünen bild jetzt schauen wir mal nach
baden württemberg
da sehen wir bei den unter 30-jährigen
28 prozent also auch ein sehr guter wert
aber bei den über 60-jährigen erinnerung
wir erinnern uns anrainer waren es fünf
prozent
hier sind es 35 prozent mit sieben
prozentpunkten zu gewinnen das heißt
auch die grünen will dann da im unions
revieren danke ich dir spannend
professor debus politikwissenschaftler
von der uni mannheim steht uns heute zur
verfügung für diese analysen und fragen
wenn ich mir das angucken baden
württemberg die meisten oder sagen wir
den größten größte wählergruppe der
grünen in baden württemberg sind die
über 65-jährigen wie ist das zu erklären
mit ihrem programmatischen profil aber
natürlich auch mit der version von herrn
kretschmann und seine eigenschaften man
herr kretschmann kommt durchaus sehr
konservativ über attraktiv sind für
ältere wählergruppen werden die grünen
wirken hier durchaus strukturkonservativ
und wenn man jetzt annimmt dass ältere
menschen eher konservativ sind dass man
ein bisschen bestreiten kann
dann sind die grünen durchaus ein
angebot für auch für ältere menschen so
und das habe ich dann den entsprechenden
personaltableau
ja das wollte ich gerade sagen mit dem
entsprechenden personal tableau das ist
winfried kretschmann in baden
württemberg hat ministerpräsident und da
haben wir jetzt auch einen o-ton zum
wahlausgang vorliegen mit sie haben wir
uns erneut zur stärksten politischen
kraft gemacht
ich verstehe das als auftrag unserem
land weiter als ministerpräsident zu
geben und diesen auftrag mehr mit mir
große freiheiten geben und damit meine
ich auch im respekt vor denen die mich
gerade nicht gewählt haben
ich versichere ihnen ich werde bei allen
was sie jetzt verhandeln als ganze welt
nicht hoch stecken wir mitten in der
pandemie die uns allen sehr viel
abverlangt und abverlangen wird
doch ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir im
sommer das schlimmste hinter uns haben
aber es ist nicht nur die korona krise
die von uns kreativität besonnenheit und
entschlossenheit fordert vor uns liegt
ein jahr der entscheidung die großen
aufgaben klar es gilt den klimawandel zu
begrenzen den strukturwandel der
wirtschaft zu meistern und unsere
liberale demokratie zu verteidigen
ich werde all meine erfahrung all meine
leidenschaft und meine tatkraft dafür
einbringen um diese herausforderung zu
bewältigen
doch das sagt winfried kretschmann der
ministerpräsident von rhein von baden
württemberg von den grünen bis jetzt
gewesen und wahrscheinlich wird das auch
in der nächsten legislaturperiode sein
denn seine partei hat klar gewonnen
und wir schalten noch mal zu meiner
kollegin andrea maurer nach berlin ins
hauptstadtstudio wie es denn das
ergebnis jetzt in berlin angekommen
ja also hier hat natürlich die große
sage ich nach schlacht um die deutung
begonnen
wir haben hier jetzt eigentlich von
allen parteien
reaktionen gehört ich fange mal an mit
der union da hat paul signac sich
geäußert der generalsekretär und er hat
gesagt im grunde genommen
dieses schlechte wahlergebnis der union
würde er damit begründen dass eben diese
persönlichen erfolge von malu dreyer und
winfried kretschmann sind in den
jeweiligen bundesländern das zum einen
aber zum anderen auch das fehlverhalten
einzelner unions abgeordnete damit
spielt er eben an auf die maske affäre
und er warnt eben auch noch mal vor
einer ampel das haben wir eben schon
darüber gesprochen ist sozusagen eine
große angst der union das jetzt eben
baden württemberg womöglich in einer
ampel koalition gehen könnte die spd hat
sich auch geäußert da besteht die
deutung der partei sozusagen darin dass
sie mit marc dreier erfolgreich in
dieses war ja gestartet ist nicht
sozusagen dabei fällt glaube ich in
dieser glanzvollen geschichte er runter
dass die spd in baden württemberg laut
den prognosen jetzt hinter noch hinter
der afg liegt das ist sozusagen nicht so
glanzvoll in baden-württemberg aber lars
klingbeil der generalsekretär hat eben
auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass es
mehrheiten jenseits der union gibt und
hat damit eben auch noch mal darauf
angespielt dass sozusagen die ampel ja
als mögliche koalitionsoptionen jetzt
auch noch mal als signalwirkung
sozusagen in den bund getragen wird die
grünen haben wir eben auch kretschmann
gehört die für die ist es natürlich ein
super tag den feiern sie auch
entsprechend in baden württemberg sind
sie jetzt zum dritten mal sozusagen
bestätigt das heißt man kann in wahrheit
schon sagen sie sind eine etablierte
volkspartei in baden württemberg die die
fdp da haben wir eben auch christian
lindner bettina schausten gehört ja die
sozusagen ist was die ein ampel kurs
betrifft einerseits sagt auch der
generalsekretär wissing die ampel ist
bestätigt worden
man sei nun bereit für gespräche mit den
grünen aber christian lindner selbst ist
ja bekannt dafür dass er für schwarz
gelb auch immer geworben hat also es ist
interessant was ich da jetzt in der fdp
eben tut ob es da möglicherweise auch
eine annäherung zu grünen und spd geben
könnte und jetzt noch ganz kurz zur afd
die zeigt sich zufrieden wie sie sagt da
die ergebnisse sind ja in beiden
bundesländern schlechter als 2016
gewesen
all dies weidl sagt es habe mit den
widrigen bedingungen eben zu tun gehabt
vor allem mit dem wahlkampf eben mutter
corinna bedingungen und die querelen um
den verfassungsschutz darauf schiebt die
afg auch sozusagen mögliche verluste ja
das passt mir auffällt wenn ich darauf
gucke ist das jedoch die ergebnisse in
den einzelnen bundesländern sehr weit
auseinanderliegen hast du ja schon
gesagt spd in rheinland-pfalz stärkste
kraft in baden württemberg er so unter
ferner liefen bei den grünen genau
andersrum stärkste kraft in baden
württemberg in rheinland-pfalz eher
unter ferner liefen
kann man jetzt eigentlich davon ableiten
das was immer gedacht wird dass die
ergebnisse in den land in den
landesparlamenten eigentlich mit mit dem
wie die bundespolitik aus sie gar nicht
so viel zu tun hat weil das dann doch
jetzt sehr weit auseinander geht ja ich
glaube da sozusagen die erklärung dafür
sind vielschichtig
man hat viel mit den personen
kretschmann und und manu drei jahren
natürlich zu tun die hohe
beliebtheitswerte haben und teilweise
eben auch unabhängig von ihren parteien
wahrgenommen werden es hat bestimmt auch
was mit dem amtsinhaber bonus in dieser
pandemie zu tun
das heißt die sichtbarkeit der
ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidentin ist in dieser phase
wo man ja eigentlich wahlkampf nur
online machen kann und und gleichzeitig
aber sozusagen sichtbarkeit über die
bund länder konferenzen oder so erwirbt
das ist natürlich für amtsinhaber
tatsächlich so zu sagen
ein vorteil würde ich sagen und an sich
es ist ja also das ist tatsächlich
glaube ich ein teil der erklärung der
aber ganz sicher viel auch mit dem
persönlichen beliebtheitswerten der
beiden zu tun hat tja und da ist halt
spannend wie die jeweiligen der
personalien in den bund bei den wählern
ankommen werden auch dass wenn wir
dieses jahr noch sehen im september ist
ja die bundestagswahl bis dahin ist
nicht mehr ganz so viel zeit klingt
lange aber sind im endeffekt ja nur
sechs monate
andrea bist aber eben noch mal vielen
dank für deine einschätzungen und für
die aktuellen trends aus berlin
und wir schreiben jetzt nochmal zu
professor marc debus
politikwissenschaftler von der uni
mannheim ich habe hier einige fragen für
sie aus der zuschauerschaft
zusammengesammelt
schauen wir noch mal geradezu den brief
waren da gibt es einige fragen also sind
bei diesen prognosen die briefwahlen
schon mit dazugerechnet herr professor
debus dazu gerechnet wird quasi
geschätzt wie die entscheidung verhalten
der briefwähler sich unterscheidet von
den wählern
das ist eine ziemlich große
herausforderung weil einfach der
briefwähler anteil viel höher ist als
früher und sich auch die zusammensetzung
der briefwähler aufgrund der korona
pandemie deutlich von der
zusammensetzung frühjahr briefwähler
unterscheidet dementsprechend kann sich
hier immer noch einiges verschieben
dann gibt es eine frage von tim
brandeisen auf youtube der möchte wissen
wofür stehen diese freien wähler
eigentlich genau also was für eine
partei ist das kann man das so überhaupt
zusammenfassen oder sind da ist es nicht
etwas sehr heterogen ist was in den
einzelnen regionalen parlamenten wieder
ganz anders aussieht
ja das ist richtig einmal können die
freien wähler je nach dem programm was
sie sich auf kommunaler ebene geben
durchaus voneinander unterscheiden
wenn man sich die landtagswahl programm
anschaut in baden-württemberg und in
rheinland-pfalz sind es parteien der
mittel vielleicht ein bisschen der
rechten mittels kommen formulierung im
prinzip vor dass man für eine liberale
gesellschaft ein wird aber auch für
die konservative positionen jeweils ein
stück weit hervorhebt in hinblick auf
freien markt und entsprechende rücknahme
von regulierung dementsprechend ist es
eine zentristische partei die man
tendenziell eher in der mitte oder
leicht rechts der mitte einsortieren
könnte und wenn man die wahlprogramme
analysen sich anschaut dann findet man
die in der tat in der nähe von cdu und
fdp häufig ich wollte gerade sagen das
klingt so ein bisschen so nach einer
alternative für leute die auch cdu und
fdp aus irgendwelchen gründen keine lust
mehr haben und sich dann für die
entscheidung in sachen corona politik
wie stellen sich die freie wähler darauf
glaube zumindest in den
landtagswahlprogramm in baden
württemberg durchaus betonen dass man
auch im hinblick zur stärkung der
wirtschaft ein stückweit skeptisch
gegenüber diesen einschränkungen jeweils
ist und hier erklärt sich möglicherweise
dann auch ein gewisser zulauf gerade von
möglicherweise von der masken affäre bei
der cdu für ihren eigentlichen
unionsanhängern dass man hier mit den
freien wählern der partei gefunden hat
zu denen man ausweichen konnte und ich
habe gerade gehört wir haben jetzt auch
einen o-ton vorliegen von der cdu in
rheinland-pfalz nämlich von christian
baldauf dem herausforderer von malu
dreyer der es nicht geschafft hat sie
quasi vom ministerpräsidenten thron zu
stoßen hört mal rein
wir alle wissen dass wir lieber die nähe
hergestellt hätten uns feste fußball
spielen
viele andere möglichkeiten gewünscht
hätten um unsere richtigen positionen
auch darzustellen
das war nicht möglich wir haben aber aus
dieser situation das beste gemacht was
wir haben machen können und ich werbe
dafür nicht den kopf hängen zu lassen
es ist noch keine vier wochen her da
waren die umfragen völlig anders und es
kam natürlich einiges dazwischen was uns
keinen rückenwind verpasst hat und was
wahrscheinlich auch dazu beigetragen hat
dass die wahlbeteiligung so ist wie sie
ist und sich auch menschen die uns
zugeneigt sind über überlegt haben
dieses mal bei uns das kreuz zu machen
ja es kam einiges dazu das dazu geführt
hat dass das ergebnis ist wie es ist
professor debus das ist glaube ich
verglasung verklausuliert us politik
sprich für die masken affäre hat uns
einen dämpfer verpasst oder in den
letzten wochen da kann so ein bisschen
natürlich noch sagen einem gewissen grad
auch glück im unglück gewesen für die
union das ist und viele briefwähler gab
die dann ihre entscheidung vielleicht
schon vor bekanntwerden der masken
affäre getroffen haben dann möglich wäre
ansonsten das ergebnis für die union
noch schlechter ausgefallen
das scheint jetzt gerade julia klöckner
die landschaft staatsministerin im bund
hinter ihm hat quasi ihm versucht den
rücken zu stärken gab es denn da
überhaupt genug stärkung aus dem bund
für herrn bald aus sicherlich gab es zur
stärkung und die frage ist aber wann wie
groß sind die chancen überhaupt gegen
eine so populäre amtierende
ministerpräsidentin anzukommen
es gab aber auch für die cdu in baden
württemberg noch in den letzten monaten
in der letzten hälfte des jahres 2020
durchaus gute zahlen aber was sie halt
häufig sehen ist und dass wir auch in
zürich zeigen können wählerinnen und
wähler entscheiden sich nicht mehr sechs
monate oder sechs bis acht wochen vor
der wahl sondern immer mehr relativ
kurzfristig vor der wahl dementsprechend
wichtig sind auch wahlkämpfe und
dementsprechend wichtig sind natürlich
auch ereignisse die dann eintreten wie
die masken affäre oder auch wie die an
dem zu wachsende an wachsende kritik an
der handhabung der kogit 19 pandemie und
ihrer bewältigung
also ich lese auch hier bei den
kommentaren sehr viele kritische stimmen
was die cdu angeht also sehr viel
enttäuschung sehr viel viel frust
schildhauer ton von leser auf youtube er
also christian walldorf redet wie ein
fußballtrainer nachdem das spiel
verloren wurde
ich glaube das passt ganz gut das klang
ein bisschen tatsächlich ähnlich geht
schau mal ich hatte gerade auch eine
frage glaube ich an sie genau da ging es
um die öffnungen die krone auf
in der letzten woche wie schätzen sie
diesen effekt eines sieht jetzt so aus
als wäre das ganze zu früh geschehen
klingt nach wähler fangen die
regierungen bzw kurze antwort wenn der
druck in der bevölkerung war da auf der
einen seite zu öffnen gleichzeitig weiß
man aber auch um die anwachsende
anwachsenden zahl an infektionen
es ist schwer ich glaube ich für
politische entscheidungsträger momentan
die ergebnisse aus der wissenschaft hier
zu berücksichtigen und ein tolles
zuzulassen
man sieht muss man auch an die anderen
faktoren denken kinder können nicht in
die schule geschäfte bleiben geschlossen
existenzen stehen auf den auf dem spiel
dementsprechend ist das sehr schwierige
gratwanderung die politische
entscheidungsträger hier treffen müssen
obgleich hier wirklich nur stimmenfang
dahinter steckt glaube ich nicht
unbedingt
vielen dank bisher immer so debus
besprechen uns nachher weiter jetzt
schalten wir erstmals für den kollegen
von der 19 uhr heute denn die haben die
aktuellsten zahlen für uns
[Musik]
jubel bei den grünen in baden
württemberg bleibt die partei von
ministerpräsident kretschmann weit vorn
in rheinland pfalz kann
spd-ministerpräsidentin drei arbeiter
regieren preisen ohne auflagen die
balearen sind kein corona risikogebiet
mehr in deutschland steigt die inzidenz
weiter schule öffnungen geraten
zunehmend in die kritik
und auf zu olympia mit einem sieg gegen
algerien qualifizierten sich die
deutschen handballer für tokio
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers
ich freue mich dass sie bei uns sind
norbert lehmann kümmert sich nachher in
der sendung um den sport ein stück von
mir
dieser sonntag ist der start ins
superwahljahr für deutschland in eines
das es so
wegen der pandemie gibt es eine
rekordzahl von brief wählerinnen und
wählern bei den landtagswahlen in
baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
heute nach den ersten hochrechnungen
sieht es so aus als können
ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer in mainz
und ministerpräsident winfried
kretschmann in stuttgart ihre ämter
behalten
spd und grüne würden danach jeweils
stärkste parteien interessant werden die
künftigen koalition und für den ganz
aktuellen stand gehen wir jetzt live ins
zdf wahlstudio zu matthias fornoff
gelang matthias grünert christian guten
abend es gibt frische zahlen zu baden
württemberg das ist die hochrechnung von
19 uhr
die schauen wir uns jetzt mal an demnach
kommen die grünen auf 30,9 prozent mit
leichten zugewinnen die cdu
das sind die gewinne und verluste sehen
sie unterhalb der balken die cdu 22,9
die afd 12,5 die spd 10 7 die fdp 11,5
die linke 3,6 prozent wäre also wie
bisher immer nicht in mainz eine
stuttgarter vertreten die freien wähler
3 prozent und jetzt schauen wir auf die
sitze im stuttgarter landtag die
absolute mehrheit liegt bei 76 da sind
überhang und ausgleichsmandaten stand
jetzt schon eingerechnet 151 sitze
insgesamt die grünen kämen auf 53 die
cdu auf 39 afd 21 spd 18 und die fdp 20
sitze und jetzt müssen wir gucken wer
erreicht diese absolute mehrheit von 76
in welcher koalition
grüne und cdu die derzeit regieren
schaffen das deutlich 92 sitze grüne mit
der spd schaffen es nicht da fehlen fünf
sitze grüne und fdp
da fehlen vier sitze grüne spd und fdp
das dreierbündnis das wäre die
alternative nach den zahlen im moment
die absolute mehrheit 76 auch geschafft
schauen wir nach rheinland pfalz
die hochrechnung von 19 uhr 2 die spd
34,2 prozent auch hier gewinne zu 2016
und verluste unterhalb der balken cdu
26.5 afd 9,8 fdp 6,0 grüne 8,5 linke 2,6
auch nicht im landtag vertreten die
freien wähler aber mit 5,8 prozent was
heißt das in der sitzverteilung im
mainzer landtag die absolute mehrheit
liegt bei 51 101 sitze gibt es über hans
ausgleichsmandaten gab es noch nie die
spd 38 sitze die cdu 30
die afg f die fdp 7 die grünen 9 und die
freien wähler hätten sechs sitze die
absolute mehrheit noch mal 51 sitze die
braucht man zum regieren und wir schauen
mal was demnach möglich wäre
das dreierbündnis das derzeit regiert
spd grüne fdp käme drüber über die 51
mit 54 das reicht also für rot grün
würde ist nicht reichen für die große
für die große koalition würde es
deutlich reichen für eine koalition spd
grüne und freie wähler falls das
politisch überhaupt eine option ist
würde es auch reichen und auch dass die
frage ob es realistisch ist ich saß aber
trotzdem mal cdu grüne fdp 46 das würde
ebenfalls nicht reichen in beiden
ländern haben wir eine wahlbeteiligung
von etwa 65 prozent ziemlich
durchschnittlich für landtagswahlen und
etwas schwächer als vor fünf jahren
da aber war die flüchtlings diskussion
im mittelpunkt und hat sehr polarisiert
matthias du hast die wahlbeteiligung
schon angesprochen jetzt gab es ja heute
einen enorm hohen anteil von
briefwählerinnen und briefwähler
wie wirkt der sich dann auf die
genauigkeit dieser hochrechnungen aus
also anders gefragt sind dann auch
überraschungen möglich
naja soviel briefwahl war noch nie das
kann man klar sagen und das hat
rückwirkungen für die meinungsforscher
es macht ihnen das geschäft schlichtweg
schwerer daten kommen später es dauert
länger auszuzählen in den wahllokalen
das hat aber auch mit abstandsregeln zu
tun und deshalb müssen wir im moment
sagen ein bisschen vorsichtig muss man
mit den zahlen umgehen unsere
forschungsgruppe wahlen rechnet damit
dass wir diesen frühen zahlen am abend
das ist größere abweichungen pro partei
geben könnte
für das normalerweise sehen im moment
vielen dank matthias fornoff und dann
schauen wir traditionell in dieser 19
uhr sendung am wahlsonntag auf die
reaktionen der spitzenleute in beiden
ländern und beginnen in baden
württemberg mit bettina schausten in
stuttgart halle bettina ja so ist es
vielen dank christian und wir sind hier
im großen rund versammelt das volk den
abstandsregeln die notwendig sind müssen
uns aber trotzdem knapp halten alle sind
gekommen und wir beginnen natürlich beim
wahlsieger in baden württemberg winfried
kretschmann zum zweiten mal
wiedergewählt als ministerpräsident des
landes und die meist gestellte frage an
sie ist heute abend natürlich wie machen
sie jetzt weiter geht es weiter mit
grünen schwarz sie haben da durchaus
sympathien erkennen lassen im vorfeld
oder geht freund baden württemberg von
kretschmann ein ampelsignal aus in
dieses war 21 also erstmal freue ich
mich natürlich dass wir wieder bestätigt
worden sind als stärkste politische
kraft in baden württemberg daraus leidig
in der tat den auftrag ab eine neue
regierung zu bilden und wie es der
brauch ist werde ich dazu gespräche
führen mit den demokratischen parteien
im landtag und damit keine spekulation
entstehen mache ich es einfach in der
reihe der größe in der reihenfolge und
dann wird man sehen was sich daraus
ergibt also keine vorfestlegung
susanne eisenmann die cdu in baden
württemberg hat das schlechteste
ergebnis in ihrer geschichte eingefahren
welche konsequenzen sind ziehen sie
daraus muss die partei personell neu
aufgestellt werden
zunächst mal gratuliere ich winfried
kretschmann von den grünen zu diesem
hervorragenden wahlerfolg und es ist
auch deutlich geworden dass muss man
sagen dass die baden-württemberger
winfried kretschmann weiterhin als
ministerpräsident haben wollten das
gehört einfach zur wahrheit dazu und die
cdu hatte ein enttäuschendes ergebnis
ein desaströses ergebnis das muss man
absolut auch das ehrlich sagen für das
ich natürlich verantwortung übernehme
aber die cdu wird intern und in aller
offenheit aber auch aufarbeiten
warum sie seit zehn jahren schritt für
schritt an zustimmung in baden
berg verliert auch das gehört natürlich
dazu perspektive aufzuarbeiten und neue
perspektiven sich zu erarbeiten und
ansonsten natürlich ist die cdu
gesprächsbereit aber zunächst mal muss
man natürlich sich auch mit den
konsequenzen aus dem heutigen
wahlergebnis befassen andreas stoch ist
der spd-spitzenkandidat herr stoch das
ist ein miserables ergebnis für die spd
das schlechteste auch sie leiten daraus
trotzdem ab mitzuregieren haben
wahrscheinlich gerade gehört und warten
jetzt auf die gespräche die wähler sehen
das offenbar nicht so in frau schausten
das ist sicherlich nicht das ergebnis
das ich mir für meine spd gewünscht habe
aber man muss eben auch sagen die
wählerinnen und wähler haben gerade wenn
es in dem politischen feld mitte links
winfried kretschmann den grünen den
vorzug gegeben das war bei der letzten
wahl schon so dass eine starke
verschiebung innerhalb dieses lagers gab
in richtung der grünen ich möchte auch
winfried kretschmann ganz herzlich
gratulieren zu seinem wahlerfolg erster
wahlsieger und hat den auftrag die neue
regierung zu bilden aber wir haben von
anfang an gesagt diese regierung der
letzten fünf jahre aus grünen und cdu
hat wichtige themen nicht angepackt
nicht vorangebracht und wir haben immer
gesagt wir brauchen in baden württemberg
nicht wegen der spd sondern wegen der
menschen in diesem land mit neue
regierung die die wichtigen themen
anpackt den wohnungsbau die
bildungsgerechtigkeit und dafür brauchst
glaube ich eine neue regierung und wenn
die spd dort sozialdemokratische politik
einbringen kann dann stehen für diese
gespräche natürlich offen fast schon
eine bewerbungsrede dankeschön hans
ulrich rülke von der fdp die fdp konnte
zulegen wie wollen sie jetzt den
ministerpräsidenten von einer ampel
überzeugen
nun zunächst einmal gratuliere ich auch
winfried kretschmann zu diesem
wahlerfolg
es ist klar geworden die menschen wollen
dass er weiter das amt des
ministerpräsidenten in baden württemberg
ausfüllt kann aber sagen dass wir als
fdp glaube ich der gewinner dieser wahl
sind wir haben am meisten stimmen
zugelegt wir haben offensichtlich das
beste ergebnis in baden-württemberg
erzielt seit 1968 und ich habe im
wahlkampf immer deutlich gemacht die fdp
strebt eine regierungsbeteiligung an
offensichtlich ist es so dass die
menschen
land baden württemberg das auch wünschen
es liegt jetzt bei ministerpräsident
kretschmann er hat ja gesagt er möchte
mit den demokratischen parteien
sondieren
der kollege teurer mein
landesvorsitzender nicht werden wenn
dieses angebot kommt unseren
spitzengremien der landesvorstand und
der neu gewählten fraktion empfehlen
dieses angebot anzunehmen und wir werden
konstruktive gespräche führen mit dem
ziel für baden württemberg eine gute und
stabile regierung zu bilden
während gögele spitzenkandidat der afg
die afg konnte nicht nennenswert von dem
corona frust vieler menschen profitieren
liegt es an ihrem tief tief
zerstrittenen landesverband nein mit
sicherheit nicht vielleicht mal erlauben
sie mir auch herrn kretschmann die
seinem wahlsieg gratulieren ganz
persönlicher erfolg von herrn
kretschmann sicher nicht so sehr von der
politik der grünen
wir haben hier in eine gesundheitskrise
sie haben wir sicherlich die erfahrung
gemacht dass menschen sich hinter den
handelnden versammeln hinter den
regierenden weil nur die agieren können
und jetzt warten wir es mal ab wir haben
ein super wahljahr vor uns und die
schäden der politik die aus unserer
sicht zum teil falsch angesetzt ist die
werden sich im laufe des jahres zeigen
und da wollen wir mal sehen wie die
ergebnisse dann aussehen
wir sind mit unserem ergebnis zufrieden
wir haben zwar etwas verloren aber wir
dürfen nicht vergessen 20 16
eine andere situation das war der
höhepunkt der flüchtlingskrise da hat
sich auch von diesem protest ja ich
stehe im besonderen profitiert das war
in diesem wahlkampf sicher nicht das
thema und corona ich kein wahlkampfthema
da haben sich alle damit verabredet wenn
man davon spricht dass er mit den
demokratischen parteien gespräche führen
wird dann zieht er wieder bewusst auf
hunderttausende von wähler so wenig
wie wir den wahlkampf nicht vorsetzen
bitten um verständnis dafür also baden
württemberg ein grüner wahlerfolg und
offen in welcher koalition ist weiter
geht damit zurück nach mainz zu
christian sievers bettina vielen dank
nach stuttgart und wir gehen jetzt in
dieser sendung gleich weiter darüber
nach rheinland pfalz wo ebenfalls die
spitzenrunde zusammensteht live in mainz
bei susanne gelhard guten namen zu
seiner guten damen sind danke christian
hier stehen hier in unserem wahlstudio
vor dem landtag von rheinland-pfalz alle
spitzenkandidatin und spitzenkandidaten
sind da frau dreyer sie als
ministerpräsidentin
spd-spitzenkandidatin lagen ursprünglich
hinter der cdu haben auf den letzten
metern aufgeholt woran hat es gelegen
ich bin ein ganz glücklicher mensch
heute oder nicht will einfach mal danke
schön sagen an die bürger an die
bürgerinnen die uns vertrauen wieder
geschenkt haben und ich will ihn auch
zugleich versichern dass ich wieder
ministerpräsidentin für alle bürger und
bürgerinnen sein möchte und ich bin
natürlich auch froh dass meine partei
wirklich so gekämpft hat und wir es
schaffen konnten unser wahlziel zu
erreichen nämlich stärkste partei zu
werden in rheinland pfalz und das mit
großem abstand und ich will auch noch
sein vergehen hat es waren sehr fairer
wahlkampf vielleicht an alle mitbewerber
auch das möchte ich unbedingt sagen es
hat wirklich spaß gemacht hier wahlkampf
zu machen klar und es ist so dass wir
fünf jahre gut zusammen regiert haben
also auch in aktien glückwunsch an die
kolleginnen und das haben uns jetzt die
bürger und bürgerinnen eben auch noch
mal das vertrauen dazu geschenkt dass
wir weitermachen können
darüber bin ich sehr glücklich es war
ein großer wunsch von mir dass ich auch
weiterhin mit meiner partei regierung
bilden darf und weiterhin in diesem land
tatsächlich regierungschefin sein kann
christian baldauf von der cdu es ist
noch nicht lange her da haben sie
geführt wir haben es vorhin gehört jetzt
stehen sie mit leeren händen da keines
ihrer wahlziele haben sie erreicht was
ist passiert
das ist ein sehr bitterer abend aber das
möchte ich auch sagen frau dreyer
glückwunsch wir hatten eine situation
die wir sehr genau analysieren müssen es
war ein von corona geprägter wahlkampf
der natürlich auch eine oben die präsenz
der regierenden
mit sich gebracht hat er gezeigt hat
dass man themen die das land betreffen
nicht so einfach spielen kann wie man
das sich so vorgestellt hatte trotzdem
lange sich vor kurzem nach vorn
das ist richtig und dann braucht man
natürlich auch eine geschlossene
mannschaftsleistung auf allen ebenen
damit das auch funktioniert das heißt
berlin ist schon das will ich nicht
sagen das würde ich auch nicht so
beschreiben wollen wir werden das jetzt
sauber analysieren ist auch nicht
einfach ein spruch wer mich kennt weiß
wir müssen genau schauen wo sind die
unterschiedlichen punkte die dazu
geführt haben ja vor vier wochen lagen
wir vorne und das müssen wir natürlich
ergründen warum es jetzt nicht mehr so
ist eine spiegel ist spitzenkandidatin
der grünen
sie sind besser als das letzte mal nicht
so stark wie erhofft es wird
wahrscheinlich auch um eine neuauflage
der ampel geben da sind sie dann
wahrscheinlich königin macherin ja also
zunächst einmal herzlichen glückwunsch
an nach baden württemberg an den freed
kretschmann ich glaube das ist für uns
grüne auch ein toller auftakt in einem
superwahljahr
und was die situation hier in rheinland
pfalz angeht ja wir haben uns als grüne
stark verbessert darüber freuen wir uns
natürlich und für uns ist das auch ein
klarer regierungsauftrag für
konsequenten klimaschutz von der kfd die
großen parteien haben verloren vor allem
die cdu aber auch ein paar punkte bei
der spd trotzdem haben sie davon nicht
profitieren können im gegenteil auch sie
haben prozentpunkte verloren
warum sind sie für 90 prozent der
menschen keine alternative
na ja die frage könnten sie in anderen
parteien aufstellen mit jeweils die
differenz zu 100 prozent bei ihnen waren
wir bei intrasolar sodass wir 2016
natürlich außerordentlich günstige
rahmenbedingungen hatten die waren
diesmal deutlich schlechter erinnere
etwa an die instrumentalisierung des
verfassungsschutzes gegen uns dann aber
auch an die korinther situation wo wir
es sehr schwierig hatten mit unseren
botschaften durchzudringen wir waren bei
weitem nicht in den medien so präsent
wie die anderen parteien und das erklärt
warum wir zwar ein gutes aber nicht ganz
das ergebnis vom letzten mal erreicht
susanne frau schmidt sie sind das
schlusslicht in der ampel und trotz
ihres hauptthemas wirtschaft das ja sehr
wichtig ist in corona zeigen konnten sie
nicht mehr punkten warum ich sehe uns
nicht als schlusslicht wir haben unser
ergebnis
die gehalten wir schauen mal weiteren
ergebnisse des abends ab und
entscheidend ist man dass man in
regierungsverantwortung dann auch weiter
akzente setzt und deswegen möchten wir
gerne weiter tun viele herausforderungen
stehen vor uns die wirtschaft ist von
enormen herausforderungen betroffenen da
gilt es auch zukunftsthemen zu begleiten
und das würden wir auch gerne in
regierungsverantwortung weiter tun
auch im streit von den freien wählern im
moment sieht es so aus dass sie drin
sind mit gut über 5% man muss doch ein
bisschen aufpassen aber wenn es so
bleibt zum ersten mal hier im landtag
rheinland-pfalz sind sie nur zufrieden
oder sogar ein bisschen mehr auf
koalitions will ich nun die
zufriedenheit ist sehr groß wir haben
unser ziel erreicht wir haben die fünf
prozent hürde genommen
und damit sind wir im reinen feld
zwischen landtag und die vielen freien
wählergruppen in rheinland-pfalz haben
einen parlamentarischen arm in einem
feld zwischen landtag und das macht
einen ja sehr zufrieden
und dann nochmal die schlussfrage an
frau dreyer sie sind die stärkste kraft
sie werden jetzt koalitionsgespräche
führen
gibt es eine neuauflage der ampel wir
müssen natürlich auch den abend abwarten
aber ich bin ganz zuversichtlich und ich
habe mich immer sehr sehr klar
ausgedrückt die spd strebt anschlags
partei zu werden und die ampel koalition
fortzusetzen
und wenn der abend so weiter geht wäre
das natürlich unsere erste wahl ich bin
sehr zuversichtlich dass wir auch
gemeinsamen uns wieder verständigen
können so das waren jetzt die
spitzenkandidatinnen und
spitzenkandidaten aus rheinland pfalz
und damit zurück zu dir christian vielen
dank susanne natürlich guckt ganz
deutschland auf die wahl in den beiden
ländern besonders die bundespolitik hier
ist ja immer noch nicht klar wer
kanzlerkandidat der union werden soll
und gleichzeitig könnten sich neue macht
perspektiven eröffnen für grüne und spd
reaktionen aus berlin jetzt natürlich
ist winfried kretschmann eine
herausragende politische persönlichkeit
aber er hat im wahlkampf deutlich die
grünen themen nach vorne gestellt
es war ein gemeinsamer wahlkampf
nein das ist ein großer grüner wahlsieg
heute abend es ist heute ein sehr sehr
guter tag für die spd wir gratulieren
malu dreyer zu diesem großartigen
wahlsieg sees stärkste partei in
rheinland pfalz zum dritten mal und hat
damit einen großartigen baltic
eingefahrenes in aller klarheit zu sagen
das ist heute kein guter wahlamt für die
cdu
wir hätten uns bei den landtagswahlen in
baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
andere werten uns bessere ergebnisse
gewünscht
die freien demokraten freuen sich über
einen starken aufschlag in das wichtige
war jahr 2021
es war ein schwieriger wahlkampf im
wahlkampf haben die regierungen von bund
und ländern die kommunikation dominiert
es ist ein wahlkampf gewesen der uns
eigentlich nicht gemäß und zwar sehr
viel online gemacht haben und wer unsere
wahlkämpfe kennt weiß dass hier für
volle hallen sorgen und dass da auch
sehr gute stimmung immer zustande kommt
wir haben unser ziel in den landtag
einzuziehen in beide landtage
einzuziehen verpasst wir hätten uns
deutlich mehr gewünscht
natürlich sind die ergebnisse auch
angesichts der umfragen im vorfeld nicht
ganz überraschend aber trotzdem hatten
wir natürlich gehofft deutlich besser
abzuschneiden in beiden ländern stimmen
aus der bundespolitik
es wird noch länger ausgezählter diesem
wahlabend wir informieren sie natürlich
weiter gleich wieder im zdf wahlstudio
und in unserer zeit erfreute app sind
die wahlen natürlich auch ganz oben
jetzt aber erstmal weitere wichtige
nachrichten von diesem so um damit von
zdf studio in seiner zdf studio das war
erstmal die nachrichten über die
berichterstattung von den heute kollegen
nebenan der großen elefantenrunde user
nennen aus mainz und aus stuttgart mit
den jeweiligen kommentaren der
spitzenkandidatinnen der parteien so
simon steht für uns weiter in stuttgart
nein ich glaube du bist gerade formel
landtag ist das richtig
diese tatsächlich im landtag jetzt denn
hinter mir beginnt jetzt dann gleich
eine große pressekonferenz von allen
spitzenkandidaten hinter mir seht ihr
den plenarsaal des landtags der ist
heute zum pressekonferenzraum
umfunktioniert worden
das heißt dass die tatsächlich in kronau
zweiten das doch so viele menschen auf
einen raum zusammen sind oder wie ist
das jetzt bewerkstelligt worden dort
ich bin gestern schon mal durch diesen
plenarsaal durchgelaufen all das sind
quasi ich glaube es darf nicht jeder
fünfte platz überhaupt besetzt werden
all das ist schon für grosse abstände
gesorgt aber natürlich ist das eine
große herausforderung so eine
berichterstattung über die landtagswahl
wo natürlich auch alle journalisten den
journalisten gleichermaßen gut
informiert werden wollen ist das
natürlich schwierig ja da alles
durchzuhalten aber ich glaube insgesamt
ist hierfür abstand auf jeden fall
gesorgt und für masken und auch für
freiwillige testungen ich habe ja noch
ein paar kommentare gerade auch zu den
prognosen die wir gerade schon mehrfach
gesehen haben die würde ich mal ganz
gerne die mit reinnehmen einmal gibt es
von bluehole auf youtube den kommentaren
mich wundert ist dass kurz nach 18 uhr
schon wahlgewinner gefeiert werden das
liegt eben daran dass die prognosen
haben und die doch relativ nahe häufig
an der realität liegen wobei wir müssen
wir sagen dann wir schon den ganzen
abend gesagt wir so ein bisschen gucken
müssen was mit dem briefwahlen ist jörg
b meint die manu soll ruhig feiern also
malu dreyer von der spd in rheinland
pfalz die bundestagswahl wird traurig
genug für die spd da wieder auf facebook
mein schau recht zu sehen dass scheinbar
etwa jeder zehnte in rheinland-pfalz
zumindest faschistoide tendenzen
vertritt das ist eine anspielung auf den
wahlerfolg der afd
jefferson meinte ich weiß nicht ganz
genau auf wen das bezogen ist schwach
von den süddeutschen bürgern ich denke
ich muss auswandern
und dann gibt es eine frage von fleck
fleck warum wird die afg in der
koalitionsbildung nicht mit eingebunden
das sollte von einem öffentlich
rechtlichen sender doch gewährleistet
werden klammer auf ich bin keine af.de
der klammer zu
das liegt einfach daran dass es keine
partei unseres wissens die mit der fdp
koalieren möchte und wir deswegen das
auch nicht denn diese
koalitionsüberlegungen mit eingenommen
haben
simon
württemberg wie ist hat sich die
erhaltenen eigentlich im wahlkampf
präsentiert sie ist durch ein
verhältnismäßig gemässigten kandidaten
während google ist das nicht sonderlich
aufgefallen muss man sagen also es gab
es keine aussetzer wie wir das anderswo
schon erlebt haben von der afd
ich hatte das gefühl ist ein ruhiger
wahlkampf und die afg schafft es nicht
ein thema zu setzen so wie sie das eben
2016 bei der letzten landtagswahl
geschafft hat als eben diese
flüchtlingskrise omnipräsent war die afg
hat versucht zu mobilisieren jetzt mit
diesem corona thema hat sozusagen
versucht diesen corona frust aufzusaugen
einzusammeln
aber sie hatten deutlich schwächeres
waren ergebnis jedenfalls nach den
hochrechnungen die wir jetzt kennen als
vor fünf jahren und insofern hat sie es
nicht geschafft hier wirklich
durchzustarten
die linke hat sie jetzt wahrscheinlich
gar nicht in den landtag geschafft
wie ist die partei dort aufgestellten
baden württemberg die linke hat serie
noch nie in den landtag geschafft ist im
knapp oder deutlich darunter
das liegt bestimmt daran dass es hier in
baden württemberg in den vergangenen
jahren immer vollbeschäftigung gab und
es eben diese sozialen verwerfungen die
wir aus anderen bundesländern kennen wo
die linke sehr stark ist eben nicht
sieht davon einfach nicht profitieren
konnte die cdos daran dass die werden
württemberger sage ich mal das haben wir
schon öfter gehört einfach traditionell
eher konservativ sind und dem ja der
nehmenden linken lager eher abgeneigt
ich weiß nicht ob dem linken lager
abgeneigt aber konservativ sind sie und
da sieht man ja auch im wahlergebnis von
winfried kretschmann dieses grandiose
ergebnis für die grünen so ist
jedenfalls meine schätzung ist zu einem
sehr sehr hohen prozentsatz ein
kretschmann ergebnis ja einer der
sozusagen sehr bürgerlich auftritt der
katholisches gerne die kirche geht der
auf der anderen seite was für
artenschutz übrig hat also diese balance
zu finden dass es kretschmann eben
deutlich besser gelungen als einen
anderen parteien so jetzt gibt es hier
immer wieder den wunsch danach das thema
dieses
sonstige lager was immer so kumuliert
wird dann heißt das ja immer ja sonstige
parteien fünf bis sechs bis sieben
prozent
dass er erst mal auseinander drösel das
ist aber gar nicht so einfach sind will
was sind denn so parteien eigentlich in
baden württemberg bei euch die in dieser
sonstige lager rein fallen die man
vielleicht war tatsächlich gar nicht
kennt also ich kenne die zahlen nicht
ich kann das nicht sagen wer da wie
stark bei den sonstigen drin ist es gab
diskussionen darüber hier im wahlkampf
wie stark eine neu gegründete klima
liste sozusagen abschneiden könnte kann
die möglicherweise den grünen erheblich
dem weg nehmen das scheint nicht der
fall zu sein es gab dann noch wollte pro
europäische partei die zum ersten mal
hier angetreten ist und ich glaube dass
so in diesen niedrigeren regionen so
zwischen zwei und fünf das weiß ich aber
nicht genau
auch die freien wähler sich hier in
baden württemberg wieder finden also
wenn ihnen den wunsch mal mit dass
unsere zuschauerinnen gerne wissen
möchten wie die sonstigen tatsächlich
abgeschnitten haben die man bis hierhin
vielen dank stürzt sich auf der
pressekonferenz und wir stürzen uns auf
die kollegin neben wahlstudio in
stuttgart denn da geht es jetzt weiter
mit den neuesten prognosen weise auf die
situation im bund auf den wahlkampf der
uns jetzt bevorsteht wir beginnen aber
natürlich erst mal mit den jüngsten
hochrechnungen alle daten jetzt von
matthias fornoff sehr gern bettina wir
schauen zunächst einmal nach baden
württemberg
da haben wir eine neue hochrechnung von
1925 unterhalb der balken sehen sie
gleich immer die gewinne und verluste
gegenüber 2016 die grünen bei 31,4 die
cdu bei 23,4 die afg 11,9 spd 10,9 fdp
11,0 die linke 3,5 wäre damit nicht im
landtag die freien wähler mit 3 prozent
auch nicht und jetzt schauen wir mal wer
da mit wem regieren könnte im
stuttgarter landtag grüne und cdu das
ist die konstellation die derzeit
regiert kommt über diese absolute
mehrheit linie von 76 sitzen locker
rüber grüne und spd verfehlen das grüne
und fdp ein kleines bisschen jahr
genauso und das dreierbündnis
eine spd und fdp das käme auch deutlich
drüber das sind also die beiden
politischen optionen in baden
württemberg so wie wir das im moment
sehen jetzt schauen wir gleich nach
rheinland pfalz die hochrechnung 1926
die spd 35,5 cdu 26,9 afd 93 fdp 5,9
grüne 8,2 prozent die linke 2,5 prozent
nicht drin aber die freien wähler mit
5,8 prozent schon und wir sehen wir
jetzt gleich was das heißt fürs regieren
im mainzer landtag die absolute mehrheit
diese linie liegt bei 51 sitzen
das derzeitig amtierende bündnis von spd
grünen und fdp schafft das deutlich spd
und grüne also rot grün verfährt das
deutlich spd und cdu die große koalition
schafft es natürlich sehr deutlich spd
grüne und freie wähler wenn es das denn
politisch als option gäbe käme auch
drüber und cdu grüne mit fdp käme nicht
drüber das ist der stand im moment bei
einer wahlbeteiligung von 65 prozent ein
bisschen schwächer als vor fünf jahren
dankeschön matthias so und ich bin jetzt
in mainz verbund mit julia klöckner
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin die
stellvertretende bundesvorsitzende der
cdu und vor fünf jahren war die
spitzenkandidatin für die cdu in
rheinland pfalz auch damals klappte es
nicht
der spd-ministerpräsident die macht zu
entreißen frau klöckner schönen guten
abend ja wiederholt sich da so ein
bisschen dieses trauma vom letzten mal
von 2016
guten abend frau schausten aus mainz
jede landtagswahl ist anders und wir
haben es diesmal erlebt dass das sehr
widriger umstände waren es vorweg zu
sagen wir sind enttäuscht von dem
ergebnis als christdemokraten und für
christian baldauf als unseren
spitzenkandidaten und herausforderer war
es unglaublich schwierig in diesem
corona zeiten wo man quasi als
wahlkämpfer an die kette gelegt wird mit
den bürgerinnen und bürgern in kontakt
zu kommen und diese zeiten sind dann
natürlich auch zeiten für
währungs chefs in den ländern und das
hat uns sehr schwierig gemacht
sie sagen im grunde war der der
wahlkampf in der opposition ungeheuer
schwierig aber das kann nicht der ganze
grund gewesen sein für dieses ergebnis
das ja deutlich unter dem erwarteten lag
in welchem maße hat auch die masken
affäre die wir jetzt zuletzt erlebt
haben in der union dazu beigetragen für
dieses ergebnis dass in rheinland-pfalz
schlecht ist aber ja auch in baden
württemberg sehr schlecht ist was
schausten es ist immer ein bündel von
gründen und die müssen wir glaube ich
oder dieses bündel müssen wir alle noch
ordentlich auch analysieren sicherlich
wir werden morgen mit unseren gremien
zusammen kommen und auch miteinander
tagen und auch diskutieren natürlich
aber sie haben das stichwort masken
affäre angesprochen das war sicherlich
alles andere als rückenwind für
wahlkämpfer die damit überhaupt nichts
zu tun haben so damit schalten wir zu
meinem kollegen carsten behrendt der
sich in stuttgart die ganzen wahlparty
ist die digital stattgefunden haben
reingezogen wird quasi vier wahlpartys
mit zwei augen auf einmal beobachtet
kassen kannst du noch geradeaus gucken
das ist genau die passende frage weil
ich habe so ein bisschen wahlparty kater
schon ich meine wer weiß wie es ist wenn
man so einer video konferenz folgen muss
über eine weile der weiß schon dass es
anstrengend ist wenn man sechs parallel
auf hat und immer noch guckt was geht ja
eigentlich das ist schon heftig kann für
das mikrofon bisschen näher am mund halt
ich würde wegen der maske ist es
schwierig zu verstehen
die bitte zu bestehen genau bitte diese
mikro ein bisschen näher am mund mit der
maske ist das alles ein bisschen
schwierig so dann erzähl doch wie sieht
denn so ne also normale wahlparty kenne
ich von landtagswahlen das ist so ein
bisschen wie freibier beim am ballermann
das wird dicht gedrängt tatsächlich gibt
es auch freibier irgendwann entsprechend
ist die stimmung bei den einen weil sie
sich das ergebnis schön saufen müssen
bei den anderen weil sie sich wirklich
freuen
wie sieht denn das hätte so ein stream
aus ja im stream es sind letztlich
videokonferenzen die wir bei den meisten
gesehen haben die fdp hat so ein
bisschen mehr studio stimmung gemacht
wir können gleich mal einen moment zeige
ich gleich aber ballermann stimmung war
nicht aber getrunken wurde schon das
eine oder andere gläschen zumindest bei
denen grund dafür hatten und die jackie
eine kamerafrau kann er vielleicht mal
auf denen ausschnitt hier mal gehen und
wir gucken mal so rein was wir gefunden
haben
das ist die spd in mainz jetzt kommt die
grünen aber natürlich gute stimmung da
wurde auch der stimmenkönigin gesucht
für baden württembergs cdu auf der
schwäbischen alb etwas gedrückte
stimmung ja und das sind die linken hier
in mannheim sprechen ja und und bei der
fdp das angesprochene studio die
stimmung also man sieht schon das ist
eine recht große bandbreite und man muss
auch sagen das sind ja teilweise
wirklich sehr kleine kreisverbände die
hier wirklich für ihre wahlkämpfe
digitale wahlpartys gestemmt haben und
das fand ich schon wirklich
beeindruckend ich muss euch noch ein
schönes stück zeigen von der fdp
die haben nämlich eine band auftreten
lassen da können wir auch noch mal kurz
reinhören
[Musik]
warschau
so sieht fahrfreude weiß ich vor die bei
den freien demokraten aus und wanna know
what love is kann man da was koalitions
mäßig reininterpretiert man könnte
zumindest einen schönen beitrag daraus
basteln übrigens eine wird geraten
darstellt ich hätte wegen dem mikro
krass rumgezicke ich hoffe du hast dich
nicht angezeigt geführt lieber carsten
ich wollte nur dafür sorgen dass wir uns
alle gut verstehen weil sonst wird im
chat nämlich in rom gezeigt und das
wollte ich vermeiden
also was ist dein fazit ist in sondern
war stream ist da überhaupt irgendwas
vom wahlparty zu fühlen oder hoffen wir
dass es das in fünf jahren nie wieder
geben wird
nee ich glaube dass es tatsächlich eine
möglichkeit eben die menschen
zusammenzubringen man muss ja auch sagen
der ganze wahlkampf war ja schon digital
und das ist eine möglichkeit auch für
die parteien für die kreisverbände mal
den helfern danke zu sagen
neben diesen abend gemeinsam zu
verbringen und auch mal wirklich die
menschen sich selber zu zeigen wir
durften ja jetzt hier in mehrere
wohnzimmer reingucken total ungewöhnlich
also das war auch von den parteien eine
große vertrauensfrage dass die uns eben
da rein gelassen haben und ich fand es
durchaus spannend und die hat durchaus
was uns auch in den nächsten wahlen in
diesem superwahljahr begleitend wird
dass wir eben ja eher digitaler als
echte wie du gesagt hast ballermann
wahlpartys haben die hier sind etwas
gediegener aber angestoßen das muss sich
noch zeigen hier angestoßen wurde
trotzdem auch bei den grünen ich hoffe
dass jetzt im ton und bild hinhaut jaja
da wurde eben auch der sekt kaltgestellt
bei den grünen karlsruhe also auch
virtuell real gefeiert gab es dann
irgendwie einen crash moment oder einen
film moment oder irgendwas wo man sagen
würde okay das ist das minimum für die
nächsten zwei tage oder ist das alles
relativ geräuschlos über die bühne
gegangen also ich würde sagen dass mir
hätten wir geliefert weil
bei uns hier einiges schief gelaufen ist
in dem moment kurz vor der 18 uhr
prognose als wir nämlich hier die
stimmung einfangen wollte ist uns ein
rechner abgeschmiert und wir mussten
komplett neu starten
also da hätten wir glaube ich ordentlich
material geliefert bei den parteien
zumindest bei denen moment wo wir
zugeguckt haben haben wir da keinen
großen fehler gemacht aber immerhin
jetzt ist das betriebssystem auch wieder
auftreten von aktuellen stand die
updates sind geladen
okay es ist kommt mir bekannt vor das
ist ein zdf auch immer so gerade wenn
man gerade das ganz dringend braucht
kommt diesen kommen diesen automatischen
updates ich bin beruhigt beunruhigt dass
das bei euch auch so ist kurz vor seiner
18 uhr prognose karsten vielen dank für
deine eindrücke und für das beobachten
dieser ganzen wahlpartys ich wünsche dir
und uns zumindest dass wir bei den
nächsten wahlen das sieht ein echt haben
können mit gedränge und geschubse auf
den gängen
das ist zwar als journalist und reporter
vor ort auch immer so ein bisschen
nervig aber hat auch ein bisschen mehr
stimmung glaube ich als das was wir
heute erlebt haben kannst mit vielen
dank nach stuttgart so dass noch einen
kleinen hinweis hier für alle zuschauer
innen im chat die sich beschweren dass
die nachrichten löschen
ja wir löschen nachrichten nämlich alles
was wahlwerbung beinhaltet das heißt das
könnt ihr euch einfach mal klemmen das
wird sowieso wieder sofort verschwinden
wir haben genug manpower und women power
dahinter geschirr geschaltet dass das
sofort verschwindet und natürlich
jegliche beleidigungen und hass rede und
was sonst noch alles gibt wir versuchen
das hier möglichst zivil zu halten so
und wir sprechen jetzt nochmal mit
professor marc debus
politikwissenschaftler an der uni
mannheim sie hatten jetzt ein paar
minuten zeit sich anzugucken was die
neuen prognosen ergeben
da hat sich ja ein bisschen was getan
aber nicht so viel dass heißt im grunde
wir bleiben bei denselben jetzt haben
wir schon die hochrechnung wir bleiben
ungefähr bei denselben
machtverhältnissen wie wir sie in den
prognosen hatten das heißt so weit
auseinander lagen jedoch nicht mehr
gerade das regierungsbildung angeht
unterscheidet sich momentan wirklich von
den prognosen dass in baden württemberg
natürlich noch spannend es ist welche
partei platz bekommt auch das als die
spd oder fdp sein wird aber im hinblick
darauf
was die alternativen zu den bestehenden
regierungen sind in baden württemberg
die ampelkoalition als möglichkeit
alternative zu können schwarz und was
wir eben ja auch schon von den
repräsentanten der parteien gehört haben
in rheinland pfalz sieht alles danach
aus als ob die ampel koalition im amt
bleiben wird so wir haben jetzt immer
wieder muss ich sagen fragen zu
befürchtet haben manipulationen das
haben wir im stream schon mal
thematisiert das ist ja doch ein
narrativ dass gerade durch die wahl den
usa zu uns rüber gekommen ist ist das
eine befürchtung die ist immer schon so
gab oder ist es tatsächlich was was
jetzt neu ist dass auch so viele
menschen befürchten dass wahlen
gefälscht werden könnten
aus meiner sicht hat das stark was mit
der diskussion um die amerikanische
präsidentschaftswahl zu tun prinzip
hatten wir das in deutschland so weit
ich mich erinnern kann in der form noch
nie gehabt aber auch in den letzten
wochen aus meiner sicht nicht allzu
prominent dass es hier manipulationen
geben können die briefwahl ist etwas
ganz normales
wir haben zwar dieses mal einen sehr
hohen anteil von bis zu 60 prozent
möglicherweise aber er war früher bei
den letzten bahn auch nicht allzu
niedrig wir haben briefwähler anteil von
20 25 30 prozent in der regel und das
läuft vielleicht abgesehen von von
menschlichen fehlern die immer mal
wieder passieren alles sauber ab soll
ich kriege gerade von der regie oder von
meinen kolleginnen hinten im backoffice
in unserer geteiltes dort geschrieben
mein main spotify wäre thema jetzt hier
im chat
ich weiß nicht wann ihr gemeint hat dass
sich spotify gehört ich habe nicht
zwischendurch musik gehört ich verfolge
genau wie ihr die ganze zeit unsere
wahlberichterstattung war ist nebenher
auch noch musik hören dann würde ich
überhaupt nicht zu kommen keine ahnung
ich guck mal kurz was die kollegin mir
geschrieben hat hat man auch meinem
monitor gesehen
ach da unten leute da unten ist ein
spotify icon auf ja und das ist das
funktioniert übrigens im zdf nicht hier
unten bei sieht es da da ist spotify auf
ist aber überhaupt nicht aktiv
aber es spannend zu sehen was euch alles
auffällt während wir versuchen uns eine
politik zu beschäftigen
herr debus wir können uns das ganze
eigentlich sparen reden nur über spotify
und kleiner
monitor zu sehen sind leute leute ok
versuchen wir wieder zu den sachthemen
zurückzufinden ich muss mal kurz
überlegen ich schauen ob es noch eine
frage gibt es was wir was passiert wir
miteinander sprechen können weil wir
wollen gleich nochmal mit einer kollegin
mit ihrer chancen sprechen die auch
gerade elefantenrunde diskutiert hat ich
habe hier noch mal eine frage die auch
immer wieder auf youtube aufkommt weil
es ja doch ein ja eine zuschauerschaft
ist die sich immer wieder damit
beschäftigt mit der frage und cannabis
also es gibt relativ viele junge leute
die gern cannabis legalisierung hätten
das ist aber irgendwie bei keiner der
parteien ein richtiges thema oder herr
professor los ich kann jetzt auch nicht
sicher sagen ob sie den wahlprogrammen
jeweils thematisiert wird es einfach ein
thema was momentan nicht wirklich auf
der agenda war oder ist allerdings
werden dann ist man doch mal in die
programme detailliert reinschauen
sicherlich manche parteien ihre position
dazu haben der tendenz nach sind
insbesondere parteien links der mitte
vor allen dingen die grün- oder auch die
linken die er für eine legalisierung von
cannabis eintreten und je weiter man
auch den links rechts schema nach rechts
geht desto skeptischer sind die parteien
da im regelfall hier geht es doch nur
nachfrage wäre die länder überhaupt
rechtlich in der lage etwas bei diesem
thema cannabis zu ändern den usa geht es
ja die usa
die us-bundesstaaten haben dass alle
nacheinander für sich leider
illegalisierten unterschiedlichen muss
man sagen reichweiten also von
sogenannten recreational kerner bist
also wirklich cannabis zum teil und
vergnügen hin zu medizinischen cannabis
da kriegt man das nur auf rezept ist das
in deutschland ähnlich denkbar dass man
sagt in hamburg bekommt man das auf
rezept und in nordrhein westfalen kann
man das einfach im coffeeshop kaufen
kann sich ja gar nicht spontan nicht
sagen es gibt gerade auch teilweise in
der gesundheitspolitik gibt es ja gerade
jetzt auch in der handhabung der kogit
19 pandemie sehen durchaus viel
handlungsspielraum der länder insofern
kann das gut sein dass hier die
landesregierung bzw die länder an sich
eine gewisse hoheit haben das zu regeln
aber das müsste man einfach noch ein
detail genau nachschauen
denn erstmal abschließend auf diesen
wahlabend gucken herr professor die woz
war das ganze eine überraschung für sie
oder muss man hinterher sagen ja das kam
alles so wie ich mir das schon gedacht
habe
die prognosen und umfragen in den
letzten 12 wochen lagen wirklich sehr
nah an dem was wir bislang sehen und
auch die koalitionsspekulationen gehen
in die richtung dass jetzt nicht kommt
offensichtlich ist die debatte darüber
ob es möglicherweise eine grüne gelbe
koalition in baden württemberg gibt aber
dennoch allein die tatsache dass wir bei
solchen koalitionsoption jetzt momentan
sprechen zeigt die stark im wandel die
stärke der parteien in deutschland ist
und wie viele sich innerhalb kurzer zeit
hier passieren kann und verschieden kann
dementsprechend ist die bundestagswahl
auch noch komplett offen aber für heute
ist eigentlich weitgehend das
eingetreten was man in den letzten ein
zwei wochen eigentlich erwartet hatte
herr professor gewusst dann danke ich
ihnen dass sie heute abend mit uns
diesen wahlabend verfolgt haben uns mit
ihrer expertise zur verfügung standen
und wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend
lange hat spaß gemacht das freut mich
und dann schalten wir noch mal zu meiner
kollegin andrea maura nach berlin ins
hauptstadtstudio die natürlich auch
alles verfolgt hat was jetzt in den
bundes parteien in den letzten minuten
und der letzten stunde zusammen kam
da haben wir ja doch gesehen die
parteien versuchen sich jeweils
irgendwie so ihre rechtfertigung bzw
ihre begründung dafür zusammen zu
sammeln warum sie gewonnen haben oder
warum nicht oder
ja also tatsächlich ist hat das große
deuten jetzt begonnen hier in berlin
und tatsächlich kann man sagen dass
eigentlich ja fdp spd grüne
das ist alles hat einen euphorischen ton
in den otönen die wir hier hören
nur bei der union das klingt tatsächlich
einfach nach pure enttäuschung also wir
haben ja auch gerade herren am ball dorf
gehört den spitzenkandidaten aus
rheinland pfalz der spricht davon dass
das auf den letzten metern keine
geschlossene mannschaftsleistung war und
schiebt damit auch indirekt einen
schwarzen peter eben auch zur bundes
partei zu den ganzen skandalen die sich
da eben in den letzten tagen ereignet
haben und der generalsekretär paul team
jagt er sagt ja auch dass ein teil in
einen teil der erklärung für für diese
verluste in rheinland pfalz und baden
württemberg eben das fehlverhalten
einzelner abgeordneter jetzt war das
publik wurde
die die spd wiederum feiert den wahlsieg
in rheinland pfalz und wir haben es ja
eben auch in der einen spitzenrunde
gehört macht deutliche werbungs versuche
in richtung ampel also wird wirklich um
regierungsbeteiligungen auch in baden
württemberg in rheinland pfalz wird hier
eine wiederauflage der ampel ist ja
tatsächlich sehr wahrscheinlich die
grünen können einfach froh sein glaube
ich an diesem tag und zeigen das auch
sehr deutlich für sie ist es eben so
dass ihr kandidaten baden württemberg
jetzt zum zweiten mal wiedergewählt
wurde damit sie sind sie sind sie so was
wie eine volkspartei in baden
württemberg geworden begehrter
koalitionspartner und auch die fdp wirbt
inzwischen um gespräche mit den grünen
denn tatsächlich die machtoptionen ampel
die hat sich heute an diesem tag also
zeichnet sich zumindest ab für den bund
und das wird tatsächlich spannend wie
diese neue machtoption diese neue
koalitionsoptionen da jetzt in den
nächsten monaten auch den wahlkampf im
bund verändern könnte
damit wäre die frage die hier einige im
chat hatten was bedeutet das ganze für
die bundespolitik auch schon beantwortet
andrea vielen dank dass du heute abend
dabei war es tut uns das ganze aus
berlin eingeordnet hass aus der
perspektive der bundespolitik ich
wünschen noch einen schönen abend
danke
und damit schalte ich jetzt noch mal
nach stuttgart zu meiner kollegin
bettina schausten die mittlerweile mit
der moderation ihrer wahl sendung im zdf
durch ist ich habe eine frage frau
schossen die viele zuschauer innen hier
hatten als es in der großen
elefantenrunden baden württemberg gerade
darum ging was der afg kandidat herr
kögel zu sagen hatte da sind sie dem am
ende ins wort gefallen da gab es ganz
kurzen aufschrei hier gerade von afg
fans können sie das mal kurz erklären
warum sie das getan haben gesehen dass
in der runde ich hatte auch vorher darum
gebeten die redezeit ja doch ein
bisschen begrenzt sein muss das ist
nicht ganz leicht gewesen unter corona
bedingungen hat man sozusagen als
moderator auch nicht die möglichkeit es
selbst ein bisschen zu steuern und dem
dem jeweiligen gast zu signalisieren er
muss zu einem ende kommen ich hatte
deshalb vorher darum gebeten dass man es
doch knapp hält und wir hatten dann am
ende das gefühl dass doch der der
spitzenkandidat der afg hier in baden
württemberg noch mal begann sein
wahlkampf neu von vorne zu beginnen und
an dem punkt ich hatte glaube ich das
war glaube ich deutlich geworden dass er
seinen punkt gesetzt hatte als es dann
losging wieder mit neuem wahlkampf
hatten wir den eindruck dass man das an
der stelle jetzt auch zu einem ende
bringen muss zumal natürlich die
sendezeit in der 19 uhr heute sendung
also dem großen nachrichten flaggschiff
natürlich begrenzt ist
das geht dann gar nicht anders denn es
warten ja auch in rheinland pfalz noch
viele viele spitzenkandidaten also da
ist jeder dann auch ein bisschen zu
disziplin gezwungen und das war bei ihm
offenkundig nicht der fall deshalb
mussten wir da eingreifen wenn wir dann
mal auf die ergebnisse schauen die wir
heute abend präsentiert bekommen haben
wie würden sie die einen ordnen das war
jetzt doch haben wir gerade auch schon
gehört von professor debus von der uni
mannheim relativ nahe an den umfragen
die wir auch im politbarometer hatten
das heißt eine richtig große
überraschung gab es jetzt in den beiden
bundesländern nicht oder
ja also es gab an der spitze jetzt nicht
die überraschung war natürlich wahlsiege
für kretschmann und drei jahren in wann
wird mögen rheinland pfalz vorhergesagt
wurden aber der wahlabend bestimmtes das
habe ich oft genug erlebt man muss den
wahlabend abwarten das ist schon so
nachher kann man sagen ist ja langweilig
weil die form fragen so gut lagen ich
bin dankbar dass sie gut lagen ja man
konnte damit rechnen und das ist auch
ehrlich gesagt eingetreten aber ich
finde trotzdem diese doppel war wirklich
alles andere als langweilig denn da ist
doch jetzt einfach zum auftakt eines
bundestagswahl jahre so viel musik drin
so viele aspekte die es jetzt zu
diskutieren gibt da steht auch die frage
im raum was ist jetzt die botschaft für
die cdu die union hat noch keinen
kanzlerkandidaten
was meinen sie was da jetzt in berlin
los ist was diskutiert wird und
telefoniert wird wie geht armin laschet
damit um
es ist im grunde so ein erster
stimmungstest gewesen er muss sich jetzt
eigentlich sehr davon absetzen ich habe
an der stelle sagen wir werden morgen
eine sendung was nun herr laschet machen
ich glaube darauf darf man bestanden
früher gespannt sein wie er damit umgeht
mit dieser situation das ist das eine
bei der union und das andere ist eben
die frage machtoption ich glaube dass
das hat bei euch gerade schon eine rolle
gespielt
dadurch dass jetzt im südwesten das
thema ampel so in den vordergrund kamen
in rheinland pfalz ist die ampel
bestätigt in baden württemberg ist sie
eine mögliche die grüne ampel eine
mögliche variante
das bekommt natürlich jetzt auch noch
mal fahrt für den bundestagswahlkampf
denn da zeigt sich dann tatsächlich am
horizont eine machtoption ohne union und
das werden sich die anderen natürlich
nicht entgehen lassen
packen sie den garaus gefühl wenn sie
mit den kandidatinnen gesprochen haben
dass das in baden württemberg
tatsächlich auch in die nähe rücken
könnte dass die cdu die opposition
zurück muss habe ich sie schlecht
verstanden ich glaube es war die frage
nach koalition in baden württemberg also
grün schwarz ist es jetzt und man hatte
doch im ganzen wahlkampf eigentlich das
gefühl dass kretschmann damit eigentlich
ganz gut fertig erinnert mich so an
einer äußerung auch in seinem wahlkampf
vorhergesagt hat das große thema das
große problem was jetzt gelöst werden
muss ist die bekämpfung des klimawandels
und das kann man eigentlich nur machen
wenn man eine breite mehrheit hat also
wenn eine die die mehrheit der umfassend
ist und im grunde ja auch eine noch
konservativere partei dazu kommt das war
eine klare anspielung darauf dass er
offenbar möglichkeiten da sieht mit grün
und schwarz aber das ist klar an so
einem war eben abend legt sich dani
einer fest habe ich noch nicht erlebt in
den vielen jahren die ich das mache
natürlich muss er sagen redet jetzt mit
allen und man kann glaube ich schon
davon ausgehen dass es in seinen eigenen
reihen bei den grünen stand viele gibt
die sagen also winfried jetzt brauchen
wir das ampel signalen das ampelsignal
muss auch aus baden württemberg kommen
außerdem wird die spd drängen und die
fdp hat auch interesse mitzuregieren
also da dürfen wir mal gespannt sein
aber am ende indes hat entscheidet erst
dann sage ich vielen dank nach stuttgart
für ihre einschätzungen und für diesen
wahlabend wir sehen uns bald wieder
morgen im zdf gibt es das was nun herr
laschet da sind wir sehr gespannt was er
dazu zu sagen hat für heute aber erst
mal einen schönen abend nach stuttgart
und für euch noch mal wichtig der
hinweis die nächsten hochrechnungen gibt
es bei uns um kurz nach acht im zdf oder
in eurer zdf heute habt die ihr euch mit
sicherheit schon geladen habt wenn nicht
wäre jetzt ein hervorragender zeitpunkt
dafür
weil da gibt es ja auch eine schöne push
nachrichten und eine sache wollte ich
noch loswerden weil das gab die frage
was ist denn noch an wahlen gibt über
die nächsten wahltermine sind
ich muss das kurz spicken weil das sind
dann doch recht viele also heute hatten
wir die landtagswahl in
baden-württemberg und in rheinland-pfalz
in hessen waren kommunalwahlen das haben
wir jetzt ein bisschen gespart weil das
halt ja doch landtagswahl schlägt
kommunalwahl in sachsen anhalt gibt es
am 6 juni die nächste landtagswahl
voraussichtlich am 12 september geht's
niedersachsen kommunalwahlen und dann
haben wir
am 26 september einen so großen
blumenstrauß an wahlkämpfen das oder an
wahltagen dass ich gar nicht weiß nicht
wer das alles in einer weil sie nun
quetschen werden denn dort findet statt
einmal in berlin wahl zum
abgeordnetenhaus und zur
bezirksverordnetenversammlung wie das
bei denen heißt dann gibt es in
mecklenburg vorpommern die landtagswahl
in niedersachsen gibt es kommunalwahlen
in thüringen gibt's landtagswahl und
natürlich oben drauf der decke die
bundestagswahl 26 92 durch schon mal im
kalender rot anstreichen
da müssen wir alle viele kreuze machen
und danach sind wir gespannt wie das
land politisch aussieht so heute wissen
wir zumindest einen ganz kleinen teil
mehr und ich bin gespannt wie es
weitergeht jetzt mache ich aber erstmal
macht es gut vielen dank für eure
kommentare und fragen bis zum nächsten
mal
grund schüsse